foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
to mix it with vodka
or pinga the same thing um
she's got that genetic taster thing
where
passion fruit and mango tastes like
perfume I mean I don't know if that's a
genetic thing I just assumed it was they
didn't know how some people think that
cilantro tastes like soap yeah it's like
I don't have that I love cilantro and it
doesn't taste like soup to me at all but
mango has always tasted like perfume to
me and to a lesser extent passion fruit
kind of tastes like perfume to me too so
it kind of It kind of tastes like eating
like an Air Wick if I try to imagine it
as as perfume I can I can see it
but it's just I have to kind of
make it taste that way you know right
but I can understand how somebody might
have a genetic predisposition to where
they drink it and it just tastes like
[__] drinking perfume yeah I can I
can see that that's a little bit like
yeah it's that's kind of what it tastes
like the only mango thing that I'm
really really into is memories of India
makes their own mango ice cream and that
[__] is yeah the bomb it is so [__]
good I think it's I think it's good
because it doesn't really taste all that
much like Mako like not kind of sweet
it's just kind of sweet and it's really
really rich and thick it's like really
good it kind of more tastes like orange
it does actually know like orange
sherbet which is funny because I don't
really like orange sherbet either but
for some reason that ice cream is just
one of the best things ever and I don't
know why because it's not usually a
flavor I would be into so we got all our
Heavy Hitters in the damn comment
section already got Louis Hernandez got
murder Hornets got David June we saw him
last night at the club no that's that's
not David oh it's not the same oh it's
not the same that's David Parker oh
David Parker yeah who also goes by a big
little yeah yeah big little okay I was
talking to him uh yesterday uh yesterday
the day before online that's what that's
why we're old we mix things up
David Parker Richard Davis
yeah we saw David Parker too
we did we saw him last night yeah
although he sent me a message earlier
and he's like man that corner is so loud
because we were in that one corner and
it's like yeah yeah we were trying to
talk and we were like
where he was like what yeah I was
talking to Big Tom and his girlfriend
secretary girlfriend
and uh getting together a new business
um I'm gonna [__] I'm looking into
what it would take
learning more about the industry
to start a group of [__] strippers
male strippers male strippers yeah like
a male review
because I got access to a limo clubs DJs
I got access to the guys some
bodybuilders and [__] bouncers and
[__] but I gotta recruit a team of guys
I got asked to dance at ladies night
that's basically yeah that's what got
him that's what started that's what got
him thinking about it yeah and there's a
demand for it
and I was like well if you want me to
[__] go go dance here
because it's not nude it's you that you
can't do that in Florida without certain
licenses and [__]
dance around in your damn underwear and
[__] you could wear your jock males
yeah
yeah doing lap dances on them little
[__] civilian girls on the dance
civilian girls yeah it's you know the
girls that are chased off yeah it's
those I know that's why I laughed
the civilians yeah civilians yeah what
the hell is that noise sound like a damn
jet going by didn't it it actually kind
of sounded like a like a prop plane or
something like they're going by like
spraying [__]
like bug repellent or whatever what's
that called I don't know I don't know
crap dusting that's what that's what I
was trying to come up with so the the
female bartenders I was hanging out
there with [__] a Mongol and a
[__] Warlock and a [__] was hiding
from a war like these motorcycle gang
guys my world club guys I was hanging
out front with Tom the owner's mom who
was looking at working the door that
night
and uh
she was gonna go ahead she'll break it
up she's she's uh she's black she's
probably close to 70. she was gonna
break it off white boy break it off so
I'm doing it
you need to be a stripper
and I said I am a stripper at heart and
the [__] Bartender Bartender girl's
sitting there she goes you're hired
we need we need uh to get some male
dancers in here for ladies night he says
you can have a job I'll pay you
and I was like yeah I'd do that yeah I
got the skills for that
um I just don't know everything about
the industry but I can dance and [__]
run my mouth and [__] you know I'm
jacked I'm about you know probably a
good six months away from having a maybe
a year away from having a real good
six-pack you really to to make a living
at that you gotta have a [__] good
six bag
um so that that's a couple months away
but I could I could change my training
routine probably accelerate it if Jenny
could put up with me
because I had to [__] take all kinds
of [__]
but I wouldn't go back to Tran
yeah please don't nah nah I'd use
anything if you put me through MPP
intense and uh
I was thinking about you know but the
thing is I was going like
it would suck to do that [__] you'd be
the only guy in there doing that it
would be weird I think yeah see if I had
a whole wolf pack of [__] like
[__] two or three other Jack
[__] would sit there just
running game on them you know what I
mean just having fun then it would be a
lot because there'd be a synergy
All Eyes wouldn't be on me I mean you
know [__] I can do live performances
and sing live and [__] but it's [__]
it's more of a trip if you're up there
in your [__] underwear yeah you know
what I mean it's a lot yeah it's a lot
so it's better if there's more than one
guy in there yeah you know so everyone's
just not like staring at you right so I
ran it by everybody I'm like you know I
could assemble a team of three or four
guys probably
we could come in here and they go yeah
yeah dude Tom was all about it he's like
yeah man [__] we will have a male
stripagram service I said yeah so I'm
looking into it
because I got promotions Jenny could do
all the
Graphics that we need I can do all this
photos she's got the guys to do all the
photo shoots we need I just need to
recruit the right guys for it
because you know I'm [__] almost mid
50s now
it wouldn't be a good long-term plan
[__] having me as a headliner 10
years later I'm [__] 65.
so you I want to recruit some guys in
their 30s you know for that
I think I could do it I mean it sounds
like fun we're trying we've been trying
to like we've been talking about it and
like trying to like figure out the best
angle of approach the problem is is that
a lot of stripper Grand business you
know a single guy can do that can handle
yeah and it's single independent
so I have to
I'd have to recruit some guys that are
already doing it that would be the best
way at least one of them
and train to get the other guys trained
up see we could use we could use Tom's
Club
when it's not open we could he already
said yeah you guys can come in here and
[__] do dance class and train them
because this dance man you gotta [__]
do dance class yeah and you're training
the new guys that have never done it you
know that's
but I kind of would want experienced
guys the thing is experience guys can do
it on their own right so what do you
what are you offering them right you
know yeah you have to offer something
actually you have to offer them
something to where you know they wanted
to be in the Ensign yeah right so I
gotta see what it is
I mean having access to a limousine is
one thing because you show up in a
limousine pile out of that or you
[__] charge girls to get in the
limousine with three or four [__]
[__] werewolves and you're they got
the phones out you know and you have
[__]
stripper limo you know male stripper
limo
family Banker bothering me so I'm just
like they have Jen there [__]
recording it well yeah yeah of course
yeah well like I said I probably have to
be there recording it because I told him
I said look it's like you're probably
gonna need a website and you're gonna
need all this other stuff and I'm gonna
have to do all that it's [__] Jen
probably [__]
whip us into a frenzy too
[Laughter]
[__]
I have to run through Jed in front of
everybody else
become a live sex show oh no yeah
quickly yeah
[__] weird ass [__] hormones
involved and [__] oh my goodness yeah
this this is like I said this is all
[__] me it's been it's been a journey
me imagining this [__] like all of these
hormones
making my transformation that's
transformation making my transformation
into a [__] werewolf
yeah
murder Hornet said live stream it yeah
we could
David June says Tomlin can be a daddy
pimp to some boys haha and then John
Smith said living the dream yeah
yeah well you're like a male version of
a Madam you know basically well I mean
but you're not pimping we were talking
about it last night because you had said
something to me about
um about them asking you to to dance
there and I was like yeah I had heard
that they were trying to start a ladies
night or whatever yeah and they wanted
that and then when you came up with that
idea of like all the guys and like and I
was like that's a great idea and like we
ran it through like a bunch of people
like we asked like the owner we asked
all the bartenders female strippers that
I know yeah we asked um you know one
girl we know there that um that used to
be a stripper and
um you know and everybody and the DJs
and they were like oh my God that's an
amazing idea it's like right it's like
yeah so I have a support team so it's
not a living the dream type situation no
we have everything to do it already
so it's like we could leverage that yeah
you just have to get the right crew of
guys I need to recruit about three guys
and I don't think anyone is doing that
only anybody's doing it or the specific
angle that we were thinking of doing I
don't think anybody's doing that because
it's like
I don't know I just I just kind of feel
like it would it would go over real
really well and I think it would go over
particularly really well like um at
mannequins yeah um because that's kind
of like that kind of place well I mean
you have to take to like mannequins it
started out like I said it's kind of
like a horror themed bar and it still
has a little bit of that but he kind of
went more in a direction where now
there's kind of like like realistic real
dolls like sex dolls and stuff like
everywhere like in [__] fetish
clothes and stuff and so like a big part
of people coming in there is they're
like oh I'm gonna take a picture with
the sex doll or like spanking the sex
doll yeah
and they're they're a lot less fewer
problems associated with male dancers
than female dancers male dancers don't
need security because a group of girls
can't overpower [__] 230 pound
[__] muscle man that's not gonna
happen well and they probably wouldn't
they wouldn't want to do it anyway well
they act bad I've seen videos oh yeah
they do they do but they can't hurt that
guy he doesn't he he's he's not really
as long as they they don't do anything
illegal he's not gonna and that thing is
is that the they don't have to [__]
they don't have to [__] become
prostitutes to [__] survive women
aren't interested in that they won't pay
you for that it's just entertainment
you know so yeah they just want to feel
naughty for a few hours before they get
married or something like that it's a
different system and the caliber of
women is a lot better than the caliber
guys that go to their damn gentlemen's
club John's John's and simps which is
the same thing that's putting it nice
yeah John is a simp I mean why do you
think that the couple times that we've
actually been to strip clubs while the
dancers are like super into they're like
oh my God a woman's in here yay yeah
they're just like so happy to see
another and it's like the one that one
time that we went it's like all the
strippers were like all over me and they
were just like all they want to do is
like complain it was like not complain
but like but just talk about it it's
like how hard their life was and stuff
like that yeah that was at Rachel's this
is like a real famous yeah that's like a
really big that's probably the most
famous one in this area yeah it's
massive it's nice it's got a [__] you
can get a [__] steak in there yeah
it's a fantastic Buffet I I don't know
if it's good it's [__] five star
really yeah they got people a woman
can't go in there on her own
but she can go where she's accompanied
by by a guy with a guy I wouldn't want
to go in there on my own anyway
that would be a bad idea well there's I
I looked at Rachel's reviews one of the
times and there was like a couple of one
Stars reviews and it was always it was
always lesbians that they they weren't
allowed to go in there on the right I
didn't know so they actually don't let
just us like one woman in nope nope they
don't want they don't want to they don't
want the nature of the club to change
from basically a basically a [__]
heterosexual Club into a lesbian Club
that's what they don't want it to become
that so an unaccompanied a woman
unaccompanied by a man cannot go in
she has to be with her boyfriend or her
husband
hmm I didn't realize no they don't care
if you're [__] getting lap dances
with from the
from the uh from the strippers they
don't care at all matter of fact the
strippers are all about that
well yeah like I said I'd imagine the
strippers would be like oh thank God
they're all thrupples anyway a lot of
them [__] strippers with thrupple and
quintuple and pansexual you know they're
like that so well yeah you know
Louie says I used to drive strippers to
parties back in the day some dudes after
a couple of drinks get handsy yeah after
a couple close calls had my brother for
backups yeah yeah that's the thing it's
like you really have to yeah yeah
yeah like male strippers like you said
like yeah sometimes women will act bad
and stuff but they're not gonna like
[__] attack you or you're not gonna
rape that dude or anything like that but
like no they're not kids absolutely
would like if it was the other way
around well it's not only that is that a
[__] 200 pound man that's [__] 10
body fat can Wade through a sea of women
if he has to defend himself
they don't weigh anything sorry I just
had a visual of you yeah just waiting
for all these like women floating no
no
and a 230 pound [__] bodybuilder can
[__] Wade through a sea of men if
they're not a jacked and not on [__]
not on [__] gear
I mean I'm 200 pounds pretty much and I
can you know
if you're not if you're not a
bodybuilder or MMA and you're not in on
gear you don't stand a chance I'll take
out two or three of you
before [__] I'd be swamped here to
buy a dog pile but
because that'll eventually happen
there's limits to everything well yeah I
mean but uh nah you just cut right
through a [__] normal guy because the
average guy
the normal average guy [__]
regardless of how tall he is is so much
weaker than me they they can't I'm
talking about just the average
the only guys that have a chance or
other bodybuilders and trained Fighters
and they're all on gear too MMA guys are
all on gear
they're good real good you don't [__]
with them exactly when anyone talks
about strip clubs it just makes me think
of all the times that go into the ones
in a GTA game Grand Theft Auto yeah and
kill everyone
they're I mean they're fun but I do kind
of feel like
the ones the time that we went that we
had the best time it was like a special
event because it was like bartender
versus bartender and it was like our
bartender from like the goth bar that we
went to Hector versus some other bars
bartender and they were like seeing who
got the most tips and everything like
that so all of our so all the goth
people were out yeah like supporting him
yeah and so a lot of the strippers are
goth incline so the strippers were like
oh my God cool people
because I'm sure that's probably not the
people that normally
I have to say though I don't know if
it's still there but remember how right
across the street from Rachel's was
sweethearts with a z which was a
clothing store and that's where all the
strippers would would buy their clothes
but they had some good [__] in there I
bought a bunch of clothes in there I
think uh I think Amazon though [__]
can really would really probably I don't
know if that's still there or not I'd
have to check because I haven't been
there we used to go there quite a lot
because I like I said I got a lot of
clothes there but and shoes and stuff
because they had a lot of really cool
shoes and [__] they're real good for
like for like [__] chicks that are
thick
boots well because they have a bunch of
stuff there that's like fitted yeah or
that's like that that stretchy material
so but it's like fitted so it looks good
on because if you buy regular clothes if
you have big boobs
um you're gonna look fat you're gonna
look fat because it's just gonna hang
you know what I mean because you have to
buy a bigger size because you know your
tits are too big so it's better to like
get something that's kind of yeah it's
got to be stretchy so it stretches in
and [__] goes underneath it goes
underneath underneath the underbuster
and they had a lot of stuff like that
because if you just buy a regular ass
shirt like a t-shirt that's why I always
buy like when I buy T-shirts I always
try to get a small because you get
something bigger and I'll just stretch
it like over my boobs because yeah if
you get a big one it'll just be like
baggy and you'll just look like a square
but I'm learning from the other
strippers the female strippers they've
been involved in
little projects like that there's a lot
of burlesque dancers that are in the
goth [__] fat in retro fashion scene
that
go do these shows they're kind of classy
you know it's like striptease yeah they
do burlesque and they do a belly day
there's a lot of belly dancers too like
tribal belly dancers and whenever you
try to get something together like that
according to the strippers the problem
is is reliability a lot of them don't
show up they don't show up on time
because they're flaky I don't know if
the male the males are like that they
might be a lot better at keeping dates
because they don't they're not the
females are always having problems with
boyfriends boyfriends won't let them go
or the boyfriends that got in trouble or
[__] like that they can't make it they
got to take dick they can't work that
day it's just stupid [__] like that
take dicks
[Laughter]
male strippers are [__] and the male
guys are more available you know what I
mean they're not being swamped by
[__] dicks you know [__] uh
story
female strippers are in a in a [__]
Eternal war against dicks Dick's trying
to come from everything coming at you
they're sick of them they're sick of
Dick sick of dicks sick of dicks
hahaha
yeah they're challenged
it would make me really sad if in this
world there wasn't like a stripper or an
egg stripper that read an autobiography
that was called sick of this that would
be so awesome yeah I would read that in
a second
and it's the dudes that they least want
coming out of these simply [__]
you know what I mean they're unpopular
and that you know with women for the
most part it's what's coming at them or
wolves and who are trying to become
their Pips or and then suitcase pimp
pretty boy who carried his suitcases
around form when they're on tour and
he doesn't do anything except take half
her [__] money and he's basically the
toy dog you know like a little Paris
Hilton toy dog she carries around for
emotional support you don't do [__] you
know never had a job myself he just sits
around looking pretty
we know him
they're nice guys it's just they don't
do anything yeah
you don't do anything except Comfort
strippers and porn stars
I mean well that important job to you I
feel like because they have to put up
with a lot of [__] to be fair
yeah well that's that that's that's how
they make a living I know I'm gonna
carry all your suitcases for you I'll
tell you it's okay after I'll even clean
you up after the bukakis over and I'll
still kiss you afterwards too yeah
that's apparently it is yeah just give
me half your paycheck just give me half
the money and I will take care of it you
know this is that's a suitcase pip
suitcase Pips yeah Tom does all kinds of
stuff about the porn industry yeah
well
and all the adjacent [__] yeah well it's
you know a lot of people it's you know
yeah that's true and some of the ones I
don't know if you can't yeah you know
who it is I'm talking about some of them
that have multiple jobs
working for amusement parks
beautiful women that work for amusement
parks playing characters and [__]
also escorting and stuff you know they
none of that is you know none of that
[__] that they do above table pays the
bills
you know it just doesn't yeah and
they're open with about it if they know
you
you know so well it's just like
everything else it's like everything's
[__] gigs man everybody gotta have a
bunch of gigs like to make the [__]
ends meet that's where [__] goes because
she can go out and [__] some old dude
who's gonna fall asleep by nine anyway
you make [__] three grand off of him
and he comes back [__] every other
week so you know beat him in a stream of
Wheat and then Grandpa yeah
so she might be making three to six
grand a month off this [__] see
I kind of Wonder but I'm like God I
don't think I would not be able to do
that and take some money back [__]
gets half of it to her boyfriend's pays
the bills because he don't do [__] I
mean I'm sure in some cases I'm sure
like the money's good but it's just like
I don't I don't think I could do it I
couldn't face it you'd feel dirty
afterwards
it's like I think they feel dirty I
think what it is is they feel they think
they they feel kind of like that dude's
a sucker and I you know I took his
[__] money well I kind of feel like
you'd probably have to have that
attitude or you would eventually develop
that attitude yeah I think this was that
because otherwise you'd probably want to
kill yourself yeah that's simply
[__] this is my money he doesn't
deserve that money besides that money is
nothing compared to him nothing to him
anyway yeah obviously so yeah
I mean I guess like I said that's the
way you look at it but I don't I don't
know like I said I'm not good at
protecting I'm not good at lying I'm not
pretending to pretending to be like nice
to people that I don't like girlfriend
for hire yeah pretend you gotta like
this dude you got nothing in common with
right so I would I'm not good at that be
some sugar baby
it's not in my skill set is that's all
and those [__] samps don't even get
what they pay for because that old man
really [__] all she does is starfish the
[__] out
she's not you know
because [__] what's what's she gonna
do she gonna kill that old dude you know
she really feels like that she just
[__] starfish go to town wake me up
when it's over
yeah maybe that's all he wants yeah yeah
they don't know any better they're from
a [__] generation long gone anyway
[__] 70 80 years old
went all over here Rich old dudes can't
[__] what are you talking about
well that's the thing they probably
never had
they had to like learn it's like
watch like be as late as exactly exactly
and people have to hang out with me
they got no game they got money but they
got no game
yeah the rest of us [__] is
gonna work I've heard that from him I've
heard that from him they don't have any
[__] game
well like I said that that makes sense
yes they're they're nerds
I mean nothing wrong with Nerds I mean
I'm a nerd but they're not that kind of
nerd they're not that they're not kind
of nerd they're a [__] yeah they're a
nerd from like a dork two generations up
yeah you know
because like I said I kind of feel like
like nerd has more of a positive
connotation nowadays so we have to think
of like another word that kind of means
what that used to mean a [__] Sim
yeah but well yeah but that has a very
specific
um all right a good uh
I don't know like I said just more like
dorky they're more dorky than nerdy
nerdy is usually like a good thing I
think
because that means you're like you're
really smart and you're like good at
something
I think no
a lot of at that level those dudes
already been really good at anything uh
they they're they're yeah but I'm not
talking about them yeah they're not
talking about nerds yeah a lot of it is
kind of like generational
position you know they have their
positions in in in in in Industries
because
family connections you know in time over
time you know what I mean they don't
really have it they don't need to do
anything their venture capitalist type
guys and
they were never really
competent
to begin with a lot of them
and they didn't they don't have any game
they can't even talk
I mean they don't have to talk because
they just had money they just splashed
cash around and everyone's like oh okay
we have to do what you say now have
their own Jets and [__]
John Smith said suitcase pimp is now a
term I've been introduced to yeah
suitcase man well that's there's all
kind of like fun um uh fun words like
associated with the porn industry
um let me see wait Louie said when the
porn stars danced in the clubs they
would clean up two or three k a night
yeah um if you if you haven't read uh
Jenna Jameson's autobiography you should
because it's actually really really good
like I read it a couple years ago and
it's fascinating that was another era I
know but I'm just saying that it's like
it's not the same as now but it's just
she kind of talked a lot about
um you know you made money from like
doing porn back in those days like
movies and stuff but all of your money
usually came from like featured dancing
positions like you would go around the
country and you would like it's like a
band like showing up like to tour it was
like that that's how Rachel's makes its
money porn stars come through right
right the girls that actually work there
they do okay I don't think it's the same
anymore obviously but that's how it was
like because she was big in what the 90s
yeah I feel like that was the night
girls at work at Rachel's do okay
they'll have a couple of top earners
during the night shifts and [__]
but you're only talking maybe a grand
maybe a grand a night or something well
I mean that's a lot more than I made
yeah so but it's not like it was yeah I
mean and that that's probably just on a
real good night like a weekend yeah
during the weekday yeah I could probably
like [__] Tuesday yeah yeah you got
like 100 yeah like three dumbasses and
they're going and then evidently day
shifts they don't make much anything
that's probably where they put like the
inexperiences the new ones and the ones
that aren't real big earners because I
mean I'm not like no judgment but who is
hanging out at a strip club at like 10
a.m on a Tuesday yeah
yeah just saying
but uh my understanding now remember
Crystal was involved in all that Crystal
had to get out of it because oh that's
right yeah yeah she couldn't make she
was a day shift girl
Crystal was cute
uh she was from New York she was from
the Bronx actually she was yeah and I
haven't seen her she's a little Puerto
Rican
she's a two tiny tiny tiny tiny little
cute little she's like was she for like
four foot nine or something like that
and she had to get out of it because she
couldn't make money stripping uh the
dudes just wanted to [__] right and
that's going on you know uh some
sometimes in the club sometimes after
that type of deal and you know she had a
daughter and [__] and she just I don't
know if you know I don't know exactly
what happened if anything went down she
just quit I don't know if she did it and
then [__] decided she didn't want to
do it or or if she just said I can't
make a living doing this and just left
yeah but she did that for
at least six months huh
it might have been longer and longer I
mean we used to see her like all the
time and she always talking about it and
then she got a real job a waitress yeah
yeah
which in a lot of ways is harder but
it's probably like a lot less I think it
was less stressful
might have been better money depending
on where you are I mean I'm um
I've never worked in the Food Service I
know a lot of people have my brother has
and uh stuff like that but Crystal was
saying she was complaining this is
during the time you know remember the
club that was up the street from
independent bar on the left side of the
street it was only there for a little
while Stigmata Stigmata that was a
tattoo parlor also yeah yeah it was like
a slash tattoo parlor slash bar we were
we were in Stigmata when she told the
story she goes I'm not danced anymore
[__] she's like I can't make any damn
money so really she goes yeah the dude
just want to [__] that's only way you
can make money and it's like oh so
really yeah if you're not [__] or
sucking then you're not gonna make any
money doing that especially not in day
shift because I'm out of there and she
became a [__]
waitress yeah yeah can't blame her yeah
yeah as I remember yeah now that you
bring it up that wasn't a racist though
she wasn't working at Rachel she was
working at another one yeah that's your
second tier place
um oh I remember she told me where she
worked and I'd heard of it but it wasn't
yeah Crazy Horse Crazy Horse [__]
Lounge no no no
it was like it was a nice place but it
wasn't like Rachel's I mean like I said
Rachel's is kind of like the yeah the
gold standard of strip clubs like in
this area that might be even the United
States maybe it's like I said it's a
nice place it's massive
yeah it looks like a [__] Vegas
casino in here yeah
but um but yeah there's other ones
around here because like I said I told
him earlier I might have mentioned this
on the show before but there's one in
DeLand which is about I pass it on my
way to work in Daytona so it's about
halfway between here and Daytona
and it's been there for as long as I can
remember since I was a kid it was called
Softail and it's like a it's biker theme
but it's a strip club and they always
have they've always had the sign out
front that says 20 I think it says 23
pretty girls and one ugly one and we
were and I said well I guess that um
that catchphrase is like worked well for
them because it's been that since I was
a kid like it still says that like on
the [__] neon like out in the front
or the little sign that they have which
I thought was funny
and let's see
Zach says there's a difference between a
fun nerd and an annoying nerd well yeah
uh and then Louie said I saw a couple of
porn stars back in the day at the
upscale clubs yeah
and they're talking about murder horn it
says they charge like 20 back in the 90s
they just charge like 20 just for a
picture with them yeah which is like the
same kind of thing I mean it's the same
kind of thing that they do it like for
example horror conventions I mean they
don't give you pictures
Tom savini is not gonna let you take a
picture with him for free that's for
sure you can take a picture for it which
is bread and butter but it's like 10 or
20 dollars they're holding themselves
out too well hey they gotta they gotta
[__] just not Sue they gotta eat too I
don't mind I don't mind [__] it funny
everybody's everybody's just out there
like [__] trying to get by man it's
like I'm not gonna begrudge anybody
however you gotta make money you just
[__] do it man and I guess it's
working I mean you know
I do it's it's funny because
when you go to like horror conventions
sometimes you see these actors that were
in you know like one Friday the 13th
sequel like a long time like one of the
one of the ones that nobody saw and it's
like they always I mean everybody's seen
all of them I'm not saying that but it's
just kind of like hey I was the first
person that got killed like in this one
and then they had the whole table and
they have like a blow up of picture of
them like from that scene so
everybody'll know who they are all right
but you know they're obviously a lot
older now and it's just kind of like
well if you can make money that's like
this is the most extreme one I've ever
heard of okay dude I'm trying to make
money off of his appearance in a [__]
movie
remember in Star Wars A New Hope in the
scene at the very end of the movie where
they're gonna get their medals yeah and
it shows the rebel [__] Air Force the
rebel Army there right and then they
[__] and they all turn at once you
know remember they all [__] yeah they
all turn around there's one dude that
doesn't and he's looking at the camera
that dude [__] uh [__] yeah I'm
the guy who didn't turn around and you
can barely see him you can barely see
him guy who didn't turn around they
didn't they left it in they left it in
because it's not real noticeable right
all right the other dude well obviously
because I barely remember he's just got
a big smile on his face he just stands
there [__] looking at the camera
and every he didn't hear it he didn't
hear that he didn't hear the command oh
okay so that's the story yeah what
evidently they had practiced that over
and over and over again right
you got sick of it he didn't realize
they were actually filming that one or
something I don't remember what the
story was but they couldn't get that
right to where everybody [__] turned
because they're not soldiers they were
just extras so they weren't really used
to that you know it's like can everybody
just please turn around at once why is
this hard and that was evidently the
best take
that they got we're only one dude who
[__] up and he wasn't real noticeable
that's awesome that dude he would sell
you a picture and a photograph and a
picture of him not turned around you
know you know it's like facing the
camera in the [__] crowd of rebels
that's me twenty dollars
here's my Photography in there I mean I
like that there's probably out there a
handful of really hardcore Star Wars
nerds yeah they're like that have a
picture of that guy and they have to
tell that story like every time what the
[__] is that about yeah he's a dude that
didn't turn that's awesome
that's [__] awesome
um
let's see uh they're talking about are
they talking about cocaine yeah
nose candy
um David June said it's fun but I
haven't done it since like 2008. I knew
it would really ruined me but that [__]
is rampant in strip clubs I'm assuming
he means
uh years ago I messed with a stripper
and she was all about it yeah
uh murder Hornet said I can do it one
night and not want her for a while but
mid 90s I was doing it every day
I've only done it a couple on a couple
occasions and each time I woke up
wanting more of it so I just drank
myself into a stupor
it's like yeah let's not go down that
road let's just get drunk instead yeah
just drink myself and [__] just
crashed out and [__] oh yeah and then
when I woke up with a hangover the next
day [__] I had forgotten all about
[__] storing cocaine
I never paid for cocaine I always was
giving Cocaine by [__] strippers and
the barbiturates is a [__] people
yeah you don't want to have to like pay
for that [__] because that can legate
pretty bright my friend John Swizz he
had this band called Sleep chamber up in
Boston and he had a team of dancers that
would [__] perform live with them and
they were all real [__] hot strippers
I showed little videos of them you can
find videos of that on YouTube sleep
chamber
and we had a [__] big party in in
that bad house that had the ghosts in it
yeah we had a big party in there
and one of them her name was sin she
came up and [__] give me a big old
lip lock and put something in my mouth
like that and it was a [__]
I said some kind of drugs you know what
I mean oh boy drugs
folded up [__]
um
uh aluminum foil
so I went and checked it and I said man
that's [__] blow
and I just want to say coach he's like
yeah
so I went and started that [__]
and then got some more some more in
there handing it around
and then
I guess it was probably about three
hours into it she's trying to sell me
more you want some more yeah
yeah
so I foiled her [__] feet is plot
the other people had a whole bunch of a
bunch of it and snorting that too and uh
it was keeping us awake because
we were drinking so much right yeah and
that was a wild night man because we
were
about six dudes about six dudes and
maybe 10 of these [__] strippers
that sounds like yeah in that house yeah
it was like a wild they're fetish type
strippers yeah yeah
it was a deuce from sleep chamber and
[__] me and Eric and some
couple guys from the club
David June said my favorite is the storm
trooper that hit his head he makes con
appearances and you can't even see the
dude's face yeah he he hit it
it probably is he hit his head and when
they were when they were shooting I
think and they were [__] getting
ready to swing across the I think that's
I think that's the hit the hit in the
head one
Jasper says not a Coke guy can't really
get past the whole decapitated bodies
hanging from Bridges in Mexico to enjoy
it yeah uh yeah overcooked though well
those guys kill each other of all kinds
of things sometimes that's over women or
just Disobedience or [__]
so enjoy all the cookie ones yeah that's
what we're saying and I don't think
they're a mean I don't think those
cartels I don't think their main product
is [__] Coke anymore I think it's
[__] human bodies they're doing human
trafficking across that border I think
that's a big one I feel like Coke isn't
really a big thing is it I mean I don't
know I'm not like real yeah I kind of
feel like that is kind of demand yeah in
math
and I think the Chinese are behind that
the Chinese I believe are sending all
the chemicals to the cartels to make
fentanyl and then they're scented across
the border
and it's it's it's a it's a it's
operations other than War
that's what they're doing which is a
war-like operation that is not war you
can get around it China is [__]
eating this country up because they want
to win you know
and as weak as Americans are they'll
allow them to win because American you
just say something on the news that
American will believe it
um but no they're [__] tearing this
country up with [__] Fentanyl
uh dissolving the borders uh they've
[__] infiltrated all the INF all the
all the institutions including
universities corporations
[__] I think they own a lot of the
Senate I think they are [__] in bed
with a lot of the oligarch families
uh the world economic Forum says that
they want the United States and the
whole West to adopt the Chinese model
so looks like the WF is sucking Chinese
dick that's what they do they're under
the control of the Chinese probably
because China has money
there's constant this there's this
constant thing well there are economy is
frail and this and that that's coming
out of American News propaganda
I think they're in a much better shape
than
than Americans are told I think I think
China's a lot stronger than we think
I mean they were telling us that Russia
was weak Russia's [__] just defeated
the largest army in Europe and that was
that Ukrainian Army that we bought for
them
totally demilitarized NATO NATO has
nothing now
murder Hornet said I live on the Mexican
border it's everywhere it's cocaine even
at kids birthday parties guys
uh and then Ben talking about the Star
Wars conventions considering the makeup
and costume says guys where anyone could
sign the autographs yeah although I have
to say that if that guy came up with
that idea and is able to make money at
it good for him yeah how can you
disprove it that's what I said I got
that guy that could totally be me I got
that guy signature Louis says never done
blow weed and a little acid back in the
day
um I've done it well I've done it once
Coke got stigmatized in the United
States after the coke thing and
especially during the crack epidemic
but what's so funny is that growing up
in Brazil
and knowing South and Central America
cocaine has been around cocao leaves
been around for [__] a millennia well
isn't it legal it's legal in places like
Peru I don't know if it still is but
yeah I don't know about now but it was
when you were there yeah you could get a
whole Matchbox full of it from a local
pharmacy for like 25 cents yeah you
could just buy it like over there that'd
be like tens of thousands of dollars
worth of [__] super high grade [__]
but that over there it's nothing and
they don't have [__] cocaine problems
so just because it's cheap
they know that hey that's addictive if
you snort too much of that you're just
going to want to keep snorting and
snorting that so they just
they can control just save it for
parties yeah
yeah and if you get addicted to it or so
what it's only 25 cents for a [__]
yeah it's not like here where you're
gonna go go rob a bank and get the money
and so you know go completely bankrupt
yeah like [__] right they should have
legalized all that [__] or
decriminalized all that a long time ago
man but you see they had a vested
interest in making it illegal so that
way they can invest in law enforcement
make a big [__] ton of money and invest
in prisons that make a big [__] ton of
money and the same those same guys
invested in the cartels themselves to
make money on both sides
they made money with and then a lot of
the cia's black budget funding was all
coming from that
proven
Hugo says there's a mini series on Hulu
about the founder of Chippendales called
Welcome to Chippendales haven't seen it
but it looks like fun maybe we should
watch that like for research purposes
that was another era I mean yeah I'm not
really like the Chippendales what we
were thinking about was kind of more
like I said well a lot of the male
stripper kind of stuff is just like so
generic it's just kind of like hey they
got their little bow ties or it's like
oh the construction worker or the
there's a reason why they're trying to
appeal to a broadest so what you end up
with is they're selling to like those
girls I chased out of there right no
civilians yeah he chased them yeah
they're sitting on the dance floor in a
circle they're being obnoxious they're
just being a bit obnoxious so one of
them kept bumping into me I said that's
it these [__] are dancing so I just
started grabbing around the waist and
[__] riding an ah and then they ran
off and we just took over the dance
floor and bye-bye you know and then they
left yeah we later we'll stand on the
foot and we like to run off the normies
don't stand on the desk I don't mind if
they're there if they're not being
obnoxious yeah but it's like I don't
like people that just go out on the
middle of the dance floor and just stand
there I don't like people that dance
around like spazzes and like just run
into everybody without giving a [__]
yeah I hate that they're calling
attention to themselves and they can't
dance that's what I mean they're making
fun of the fact that they can't dance
get the [__] off the dance floor it's
like people that can actually dance
would like to dance and you're in their
way and it's the girls a lot of it you
know what I mean and what and what's
funny is that they'll stand in the
[__] Circle and you know it gets bad
when those [__] put all their purses
in the center of the [__] Circle
there you go they gotta go oh my God
we're like oh here's this here's this
little group and they just kind of go
they're white they can't [__] death
come on
hey I'm white and I can do it yeah white
people can't dance it's just the ones a
lot of a lot of them can't a lot of them
can't to be fair yeah
and it's like and I always kind of laugh
like I hate to be an app well I don't
know if I hate to be an [__] but
um a lot of times because early when we
got there early last night there was
kind of like a little group there that
was like mixed it was like girls and
guys and like a couple of the guys were
out there dancing and I was just like
are you just like trying to like show
off how bad your dancing is like how you
don't have it at least at least they
were trying I mean they were trying I'm
trying but I was like trying but you
gotta you know you gotta have experience
to you know I mean it takes time to
learn how to dance you gotta have a good
mind-body connection you just gotta let
it flow you can't think about it you
just do it see that's that's they're
trying to think about it we were talking
about that the other day because it's
like even though normally I'm like
really klutzy and I don't have like you
know I don't know what my hands and feet
are doing at any point but if there's
like music on I like and I'm just like
not thinking about it like I've had a
couple drinks or something like that
I'll just go out there and just dance my
ass off yeah because you're not thinking
about it because I'm not thinking about
it yeah I'm not thinking about it you're
doing spins and pirouettes and [__]
doing it you know [__] yeah she's
good it's good when she's you know it's
because we don't think about it there
thinking about it they're trying to
figure out where their feet is supposed
to go well in the end they're trying to
be they're trying to call attention to
themselves and their tanning as they're
doing it and they're also trying to like
well I know I can't dance but look how
dorky I am and I'm just like why don't
you just stop just stop this is a this
is a dance this is a dance club not a
comedy club yeah and even if it was a
comedy club you're not it's not funny
you're not funny yeah yeah just just
stop it well like I said I don't really
like I don't like people that just try
to call attention to themselves like
that yeah it's like look no one cares
piss off look I can't dance get the [__]
off the dance yeah it's like look how
funny it is that I can't dance I'm just
like yeah hilarious [__] off and it's
always the same demographic it's always
it's the same difference there's always
like a group of people like that there's
always a group of people it's always
it's never the same people it's always
different people it's always white
people all right and they're yeah offer
middle class it is always like their
upper middle class white people who are
kind of like office worker college kid
time yeah they're out Cutting Loose yeah
Cutting Loose they're very Japanese
almost like the girl those those white
girls were dancing kind of like the way
Japanese girls would dance like in high
school did we just kind of go they're
they're just bobbing up and down
there's no steps they just kind of just
bend at the knee up and down you didn't
notice that yeah like yeah well and it's
like whatever music is on they dance the
same yeah and then a girl who's really
cut loose is really just running around
jumping up and down like a rabbit yeah
that was not yeah
maybe she was high no no she was or she
was just an idiot she's an idiot I
called her an idiot don't you remember
that I didn't I can't hear in there she
jumped backwards into me in a [__]
grabbed it remember grabbed her by her
[__] elbows because she and I went I
pushed her forward
back off me like that you know and all
our friends looked at me and I go you
[__] idiot
it's like settle down it's like
everybody's there to have fun but Jesus
Christ you don't be a [__] idiot
don't be a [__] idiot about it it's
like nobody
nobody wants to be run into you by some
[__] [__] that doesn't know like
yeah oh look how cute I'm just like
running around and dance
everybody I'm like I'm like [__]
not enough so I just grabbed the nearest
one and just started crying up against
you
she jumped off me and I grabbed the
other one by the [__] her [__]
belt and pulled hers come on we're
dancing because they weren't dancing
they were just jumping up and down
ran off and the two lesbians that were
standing next to me laughed they're like
you're like that was great well because
it's a constant struggle
especially at that place like on Friday
because Friday night is ostensibly the
God's night and sometimes you get like a
bunch of goth people and sometimes you
don't get that many guys right just
depending on what time of the month it
is or whatever that sounded like a
period thing but it wasn't
but um it was a paycheck thing but um so
a lot of times like the gods will be out
there dancing and like you can see their
faces are like getting super annoyed
because there's like all these normies
out there just either standing there
standing there on the dance floor or
with cups or making fun of people
dancing they do that too
um where they're just like look at these
weirdos like that and then it's just
like Jesus Christ can I please just
[__] dance and so like when you start
kind of like right you can't I mean you
have to be I don't know if you have to
be subtle about it but I mean I've I've
kind of like danced and like backed into
people oh whoops whoops and then you
just keep backing up until they're off
yeah
what's funny is that oh no they left
what's funny is that they'll say thank
you David
cheers he'll show they'll show up and
they'll stand on the Dance Floor lyric
the people at the dance floor because
it's early in the night when they're
there yeah and they're like look at
these weirdos yeah and that kind of
thing and then they don't realize it but
over the next half hour they're slowly
being out numbered by a weirdos and
they're like wait a minute where am I
what kind of place is this and then they
leave yeah oh [__] oh I don't like that
yeah yeah yeah they only like that as
long as like they have yeah they have
they don't they're only like that if
they have to do Miracle Supremacy that's
kind so that's kind of why you can't you
never know how it's gonna go at that
place because it's like if the normies
outweigh like early in the night then
it's kind of bad because then it's gonna
go in that direction and they're gonna
be like well this is our [__] and we
just took it over but it's like if more
kind of gothy people get there early
then it's better because then the
normies will come in and be and they'll
kind of [__] around for a second they're
like oh yeah they're like well you know
there's more of them in here right so we
have to we gotta go so we always like
when that happens yeah you just gotta
outnumber them
and then when you're outnumbered it gets
a lot better because you got the baby
bats out there and some of those girls
are just [__] very scantily clad and
they're [__] if they're drunk they
start getting wild
um it gets good it gets good although we
haven't had a Stanley clad baby baby bat
in a while have we there weren't that
many baby bats there last night they
come I think they do once a month I have
to ask I have to ask Dave I don't think
he's here but um I think they do I don't
think they call it this officially but
they call it the baby bad invasion baby
and I think they only do that once a
month and I don't know what Friday it is
yeah because we were there one night and
I was like it was the night it was the
Friday after Sophie left yeah because
remember the night that Sophie was there
that we took Sophie and that was the
night with the fight and all that kind
of crap and like it was full of normies
and it was kind of sucky but like the
week after that we went the Friday after
that and it was just like almost it was
like 90 God people and I was like so you
never like I said you never know last
night it was probably
60 40. yeah I feel like maybe but it was
awesome because
um I was outside her favorite songs five
of them yeah he played like five or six
of them like honor man he played some
[__] he played some old Susie he
played like the Christian death he
played like the cramps I was just like
holy [__] this is awesome yeah the
church The Chameleons UK yeah and then I
want to be ignored or I want to be
adored stone roses I want to be ignored
that's the uh that's the other version
that's the Beast I know
and then [__] old Ministry
yeah although I'm sick of that time yeah
to be honest
Kitty puppy yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
um
for those for those of you guys don't
know the [__] we're talking about yeah
maybe that a baby bat is a young new
goth person yeah that's a baby bag it's
usually girls usually girls oh Dave is
here hello he just arrived just arrived
right uh murder Hornet said what do they
call older guys Elder they just call
them Elders that's what they usually
call them yeah I mean that's the only
terminology I've ever heard
it would be funnier if we were called
Old bats before that I've never heard
anything
they usually just call them elders
elders Elder gods
uh Dave says Paul knows what you like
but he has a Jenny file yeah because if
honestly most of the time like in early
in the night if he sees me in there
he'll usually play yeah like Nick Cave
or something like that like when no one
else is dancing he was kicking ass
that was a good run Dave was Dave was
hanging out with us in that back corner
near that [__] speaker nobody could
hear anybody
as loud as it was
and uh we had a couple baby bats hanging
out with us that one baby bat with the
booty was next to us got to got to know
her I don't know what her deal was
What's your deal then it was this other
baby bat this skinny [__] looked
like Egon from
he's gonna bring those up there I'm
gonna go there he's it
I'm gonna go there okay we're gonna talk
about it all right
there's just nerdy redhead chick was
next to us right and I go Jen there's a
new girlfriend because he said I was
checking around she's cute yeah I've
seen her before I've seen her at
Barbarella yeah she's
she's a look at them she looks that
younger
because I like nerdy girls so he's
always like hey there's a girlfriend
yeah which I'm like oh all right there's
this guy out there dancing he's young to
his baby back skinny it kind of looked
like Egon from [__]
Ghostbusters a little bit but I like
Egon
he look like [__] I collect spores
molds yeah he looked like uh look like
[__] John Travolta from Greece I mean
I didn't get that John Travis okay he
just took a little Oily to me but he's
out there okay he's out there dancing
with uh
a couple of hot baby bats
and Jen goes he's cute and I'm looking
at him and I'm going okay and I'm going
thinking wait a minute he's cute well no
what happened was that [__] go you were
talking about I remember and I was going
because because you were drunker than me
yeah so I remember how the conversation
was no that dude ain't cute because you
were talking about nerdy girls yeah
because you were like oh then you know
and you were like oh and then I was like
oh well you know I like some nerdy boys
too yeah and you pointed to this one guy
and you were like oh that one I was like
no I was like oh that one's cute like
that was like all right yeah that's I I
don't remember how like I said I didn't
really think about it that hard I was
just like that like that guy's cute like
not this guy but that guy and then like
you kind of got all
I was like wait a minute hold on wait
that's that guy's cute
what does that say about me and then he
was having this whole like existential
crisis no it was
because we were talking about dude I
must be [__] ugly [__] no no but I
tried to explain I tried to explain I'm
like dude one I didn't think about it
that much yeah um I was just like saying
oh that's an example of like a cute
nerdy guy I say but he's young enough to
be my son so don't worry about it you
know what I mean I just said just for an
example you know that was the guy that
was just saying that covered up man no
no no I'm just saying that was the guy
that was there I didn't think about it I
really didn't think about it that hard I
really did
um so so you're saying if if you were on
a desert island
you're thinking about it way more than I
think about it no because I was telling
him before it's like I'm not I'm not
like a checking out people [__]
I'm just not I've never been like that
and I said if I'm gonna check out
somebody it's probably gonna be a chick
it's not gonna be a dude I don't check
out dudes unless they have like a really
awesome outfit yeah or unless they're
like a really good dancer like that's
the only thing I noticed so we go so uh
today we go down to uh uh [__] koiwan
we that's that's become our Saturday
Tradition now go into it I ate so much
[__] shrimp and steak you ate so much
I can't I got like I got through a plate
and a half and I was like I think I'm
gonna throw out but I don't think I can
eat it anymore so we go to Publix which
is our local uh grocery store on the way
back she had to pick up some lunch stuff
and I said I bet your girlfriend's
working in here tonight there's this
little nerdy girl where's the bakery
she's cute yeah and and [__] I
pointed her out I found her I scouted
her out for Jen says I bet she's working
in here and she goes I don't know you
know so we walk in there and here she
comes man walking right towards me and
she had blue hair well she had like her
little hair yeah she's nerdy hair net on
because she wasn't working and I went
and I said hey how are you doing and she
goes how are you doing
because you smooth [__] she was
working I couldn't you know I'm gonna
get her for you
I'm gonna get her for you I like the
nerdy girl yeah she's how are you doing
and man she just works right up the
street yeah okay
we're gonna see
where but yeah I think like I said you
worry too much about it like I don't I
literally don't check out dudes yeah
like I said the only reason I would
notice a dude I was like oh that's a
cool outfit like he looks real put
together that's why I know that's how
that's why I noticed you yeah I wouldn't
normally like notice
um dudes but that was the first thing I
noticed about I was like man he's a good
dresser like because you like you know
would wear like some really big he did
look like Egon you know exactly who I'm
talking about I like you guys yeah yeah
[__] about it yeah Egon was the hottest
Ghostbuster yeah you got look at you
gone sorry
you know how I you know how I do that
dude weighed 100 pounds man I like I
like Lurch I like I like that kind of
[__] I like that dude was probably like
five nine and a hundred pounds that's
okay so like I said he's probably like
[__] 19. well now he's making me
probably like 21. he was having success
man yeah he got that jump right on that
girl I think like a man I think she's
like a man should they were out there
[__] making it yeah
she was yeah they left him she was he
was making out with her
who's sitting down that thing making out
with her and a friend was sitting next
to him that remember she had that uh
she was with that black chick yeah that
chick was sitting there just watching
him making out yeah yeah she was cute
too she was cute yeah well actually I
thought well um she was um waiting by
the bathroom yeah by the bathroom yeah
I'll tell you know I was like I didn't
talk to her anything yeah I'm sorry uh
Louis said question are industrial clubs
and golf clubs similar yes we used to go
to industrial clubs in Hollywood back in
the day yeah I kind of feel like it's
the same scene I mean it's like merge
there's a lot of thick industrial
there's a lot of overlap I'm not like a
massive I'm more a goth person like I'm
more like a death rock postpunk kind of
person I like some industrial but it's
not usually like the baby bats coming or
death Rock
most of them and I I love that like
bringing it back looks like 80 1982 in
1982. I noticed it a lot at the zymox
show yeah because I noticed like a lot
of because probably the crowd were like
half old [__] like us and then half
like really young people yeah but they
all looked like all death rocked and
cute and I was like that's awesome
they're cute that's awesome little 100
pound girls skinny but they can it's
easy for them at that at that age but
the clothes just [__] the clothes and
the makeup and the hair just right they
did they they did their research so yeah
that's it speaking of which I forgot
that uh Paul also played Nina Hagen last
night yeah and I forgot how [__] cool
Nina Hagen looked back then yeah and I'm
like watching that video I'm like holy
[__] I'm gonna do that [__] like she
have all the blue hair with like the
[__] bangs like that and it was all
like back into all of the makeup and
everything I've I saw Nina Hagen live in
two oh 2007 2008 something like that
like like in New York and she still like
looked really cool but obviously she
didn't look like that anymore because
she was really young in that video but I
was like man I forgot how cool she looks
back in the day yeah she's way ahead of
her time oh yeah big time Camp guy says
Publix great store I use their phone app
to order sub sandwiches the boys had
Italian on white large yeah I mean I get
every time I go to multi-conflicts yeah
I get the multi-grain bread is so good
get the multigrain I get roast beef
Swiss
with [__] those [__] pickles
that's where this guy pickles yeah I get
garlic pickles banana peppers do not get
lettuce it's too [__] wet I get
spinach [__] I get spinach raw spinach
on it and I like tomatoes on mine yeah I
don't get the tomatoes I know because
you think they're too wet but I like it
and then uh I don't like too much water
in it and uh onions and uh the damn
banana peppers
Mayo just mayo man
now you guys think that you guys you
should go tomorrow again
public Publix [__] sandwich shop is
the best [__] sandwich shop I've been
all over the United States that's the
best sandwich sub sandwiches you can get
they're all cold though I don't think
that women do they have a meatballs up
yeah yeah do they have hot ones okay
they have hot ones okay yeah I guess
they did didn't they yeah yeah I don't
think I've ever had a hot one from there
though no because it's like I always
think about getting a different one when
I go but I'm like man that [__]
original
they make them to order kind of like a
Subway
I said you can actually order them
online like I had because if you I went
to the public to do this we wanted to
wait yeah well because I went to Publix
the other night like to get something to
eat and like I was gonna get a sub but
then the line was like enormous and I
was like [__] that that's like because
they usually only have one person making
sandwiches
you get the full size one man it's huge
yeah you can it's two meals yeah I can't
eat the whole thing that's why I don't
want lettuce on there because if you
only eat half
you go back in the other half of the
lettuce that's released all its water
inside the bread and it's [__] soggy
but if you put raw spinach in there it
doesn't release all that water yeah so
the other half of that sandwich would be
good for the whole day yeah you know
I don't like any water in there same
thing what happened with raw tomato the
water will seep out but I like tomatoes
so much that it's like I always you
gotta eat it right then yeah you know
what I mean if you can have all that
water in the sandwiches you've got to
eat it right then you can't let it sit
around it'll get soggy and if you're
gonna take it home I would also advise
like getting the dressing on the side
yeah pour it on there before you go
before you know right before you eat it
I mean even though it's only like down
the street
it's a what is it
it's not it's not a vinaigrette it is a
vinegar it is kind of what do they call
it I don't know
it's Greek dressing I think one of the
Italian dressing no
it's not Italian dress they just call it
oil and vinegar
no don't they no I think it's I think
that's all I get on there I get oil and
vinegar and then salt and pepper oh no I
get the dressings I don't usually the
dressing I just get the oil I think it
might be uh what do they call it
you take Italian dressing and you
basically blend it yeah yeah and it's
you know I mean you blend it together
that way it doesn't it can't separate I
forgot what they call that
let me go uh making the drinks Dave says
uh I'm going tonight again to mannequins
I know David is lame that's not lame
we had we actually had a really good
time last night
because you know
it was it was really fun it was really
fun the music was good uh you know the
crowd was a little bit iffy at first but
it got better later
you know there was room to dance pretty
much all night which is always nice I
didn't go out on the patio but I don't
usually go out in the patio especially
now when it's this time of
year it's too [__] warm out there
yeah
Florida
Camp guy said I missed the Blimpy sweet
pepper slices yeah Blimpy yeah I guess
they're not around anymore and did they
go like completely bankrupt there's so
many like [__] sandwich shops now
so many Subways so many I don't like
subway all that much they're not
terrible but
Trey says [__] I missed it or most of it
I mean we've only been here an hour it's
fine we're not going anywhere so
oh
Camp guy said one trick with red
tomatoes to slice before you make your
sandwich and salt it the salt will draw
out some of the water yeah I kind of
feel like I kind of wish they would do
that you know what I mean like salt the
tomatoes so it sucked some of the water
out like before
but
Trey says all the Blimpies in The Circle
K's here in Georgia closed last year
yeah I had heard they were having uh
problems we have our Circle K right down
the street from us has a Subway in it
but I've never eaten at the subway there
I usually just get
they have I don't remember what the
brand name is but they have like all the
cold sandwiches because obviously
it's become a tradition now if we go out
at night like we stop at the Circle K on
the way home and I always say I'm gonna
get something different this time but I
never do I always get just like a cold
sandwich and like a little like a half
can of Pringles or something
and sometimes I'll get like nuts or
something like cashews or something but
last night I just got prank although I
didn't eat all the Pringles I still have
some I haven't eaten them yet and they
didn't have my favorite is they have a
chicken salad with cranberries in it
which is actually like really good but
last night they didn't have any they had
plain chicken salad but they didn't have
any with the cranberry so I got egg
salad instead
Jeffy Hart said Subway went downhill
long before the Jared incident but I
don't think it out too much yeah it
absolutely didn't
um Dave says gotta go love you both we
love you too Dave have a good time
tonight uh it was good seeing you last
night as well
um I don't like I said I don't hate
Subway as much as some people but it's
never like my go-to like I never was
like oh let's get some Subway
I used to eat it sometimes because
um back in from 2013 to 2016 I worked at
a print shop in Longwood uh which is you
know outside of Orlando and there was a
Subway like literally right
in the next parking lot you know I mean
like you could there was a 7-Eleven and
then there was a Subway and there was
like right there so if I didn't bring
any lunch from home which I usually did
then I would go over there and get a sub
but
their Bread's not great I don't love it
um and I think after a while they
discontinued their what the [__] did
they call that
Neptune salad or yeah yeah so I wanted
Neptune salad like that was like the
crab salad or the seafood salad and I'm
just I am a [__] [__] for crab salad
I love that [__] I don't know why
um when we were at koiwan today I even
got like a little I got a little scoop
of that like I said was it good yeah was
it better than mine or or
um it's not as good as yours what's the
difference you think
um it's a little bit blander okay
because it looked like the um the Mayo
was holding on to it pretty well yeah it
didn't it's good but you're like I said
yours has more flavor to it it's good
but it's just like it's just kind of
bland the problem I have with mine is
that
over time the Mayo breaks down and
becomes too watery and it's because
these recipes are calling for lemon
juice
I think I should discontinue lemon juice
maybe and go and go half
mayo and half sour cream to make it
thicker
and then you add the lemon juice on
service
yeah in other words put it on a sandwich
before yeah that way it's not being
stored in it right yeah that would make
sense I think that's what I'm doing
because actually at koiwan today I you
know I got like a little scoop of crab
salad lick with my first with just like
the mussels and the shrimp and stuff and
I put lemon juice on it I don't know if
they put lemon juice in it prior right
but I put lemon juice on it probably not
because it looked like it was holding
onto there pretty good yeah it looks
like pretty yeah but like I said yours
is better flavor wise theirs is it's
good because they don't have any Old Bay
in it probably right yeah they had the
damn Cajun Cajun seafood which is a
bunch of shrimp and mussels and I'm like
there's barely any Cajun seasoning and
it's barely I guess they just try to
make it appeal to everybody
you know what I mean [__] but if that
was Louisiana it'd be hot yeah yeah but
I can see I can't eat it hot though yeah
like it just gives me heartburn or a
stomach ache
Camp guys says the very first Pringles
Factory was set up to manufacture tennis
balls but on the first day a truckload
of potatoes was delivered yeah I don't
think that's true no it's not he's not
sure it's making a joke I know the
history of that company it's actually
fascinating it's fascinating they I
think one of the um episodes of uh the
food that built America was about
Pringles yeah it was a big challenge to
see what shape that Pringle should be to
give it maximum structural strength
inside that can so they wouldn't break
yeah and they can't call it a potato
chip
because it's not a potato it's
technically not technically not because
it's not you don't slice a potato and
put it in the fryer they can only call
it a pringle
uh and it's Pringles are [__] good
though yeah and it's it's uh
it's a potato chip made out of [__]
uh instant mashed potatoes yeah that's
all it is that's right it's just the
machine throws it into a bunch of
[__] hot oil and it just instantly
becomes a chip
and then it stacks and then they start
they stack them all up and put them in
there
was a name for that shape
it's a pair of uh parabolic something
Paradox something around something
but it was they had some kind of [__]
structural engineer figure out what
shape they should be that's what he came
up with and they do survive in that camp
you know I thought that they that um
physicists thought that's what shaped
the universe was all right yeah
I don't know if they still think that
good thing about a pringle is that you
can make a pringle any flavor you want
you just put it in the batter I've even
had to put it in a big spice yeah any
flavor it doesn't even have to be salty
it can be sweet you can turn it into
candy they have sweet ones well in Japan
I think they have like a bunch of weird
ass flavors because if you go in FYE you
know how in FYE and malls and stuff they
have like a whole section of like weird
Japanese snacks and stuff yeah and they
have like some Japanese uh Pringles that
they sell over there and they have like
all kind of crazy places like strawberry
and [__]
which like I said it's a potato so it
sounds weird to us but it's not really
that weird I mean potato is like pretty
a pretty like black canvas yeah um so
you can like put pretty much whatever
you want on there I had
um
actually one year I don't know if they
do it this but one year Pringles did
some Christmas flavors and they did like
a peppermint one and that actually I
thought was like that sounds kind of
gross but also kind of good and they
were actually pretty good I thought they
were pretty good
um they did some Thanksgiving ones too
um Trey says I rarely eat Subs anymore
um I'm all Mexican Chinese and pizza
lately single guy thing I guess uh then
it said I'm allergic to Mayo so I can't
eat any of that type of stuff like
chicken salad and so forth that's a
bummer I know a lot of people are gross
out by mayo and that's you know that's
fine but man I love mayonnaise
I love mayonnaise and I don't I don't
know what I would do if I couldn't eat
crab salad or chicken salad or tuna
salad or something like that
Louis said most of the Quiznos around
here closed years ago yeah I think
Quiznos was also having trouble I don't
know if we have any around here anymore
we have a Jimmy John's a few miles away
but that's like the only one at a subway
but that's about all I'm not sure
Quiznos could survive here I think a
Quiznos is the same as as uh Subway
right I think it's the same similar I've
eaten at Quiznos a couple of times I
thought it was the same company that
divided into two
is basically Rock Bottom that's what's
in a Circle K
yeah like I said our Circle yeah down
there has a Subway right that's Rock
Bottom
um I don't think it could survive a
Florida Florida has [__] great food
uh the best Subway chain we have I think
it's called Firehouse yeah Firehouse
Subs is good yeah yeah I had that that's
not all that is Publix Jimmy John's is
good too but the firehouse is real Jimmy
John's is good too
um it's not as good as Publix but
nothing as good as Publix and Chico
Chick-fil-A here's off the [__] chain
you could see a whole line of cars
[__] five cars wide in a chicken
Chick-fil-A and you don't have to be
afraid of getting in that [__] line
for the drive-through you'll be you'll
have your check you oh you'll have your
Chick-fil-A in about two or three
minutes those lines move [__] fast
they'll have 10 girls outside the
[__] thing taking orders into all the
cars and handing [__] out
they had some of the best [__]
curbside service I've ever seen you ever
been to the to that [__] yeah a long
time ago but yeah you don't even have to
order at the window yeah when they get
busy they'll run and jump out there and
take all the orders from all the cars
and they'll [__] wire it all in the
radio the thing about it nowadays is
that a lot of people just order pre like
pre-order through the app and then you
just go and pick it up you know which
saves a lot of sense to be honest with
you
um
Trey says remember when Pringles came in
two smaller cans and you got two cans in
a little bag in the mid-1970s I don't
remember that I don't quite remember
that
I don't quite remember that
I remember Milk Duds
they still make those I know but you
don't see them anymore they came in a
box they still have the wax with a wax
paper [__] bag inside of it oh I
remember that remember that I don't like
Milk Duds they had like three different
flavors
okay I definitely don't yeah different
flavors well I wasn't that when I was a
little kid at least I love them I don't
like that malted flavor it wasn't malted
milk not Milk Duds what were they called
yeah so we're talking about that we're
talking about something no milk Dud is a
malt ball right yeah yeah it wasn't that
I thought it was called it was a chewy
candy that was round
that's not a milk dead it was chewy milk
dads are like crunchy okay all right I
got I got it mixed because I was a
little kid last time I saw him
they were like chewy caramel covered in
chocolate chewy caramel coverage okay
and and one of the flavors was chewy
caramel covered in chocolate but there
was a raisin in the middle of it yeah
not talking about a raisinet
but it was like or better than a
raisinet what was that [__] thing
called
I thought it was called milk Dud you're
talking about Whoppers
Whoppers are the [__] uh yeah but I
thought Milk Duds were like that no like
I said that's a chewy are they
let me go [__] decision yeah look
that [__] up because I don't I'm not
entirely sure you're chewy
I'm not entirely sure Trey said Jimmy
John's left my city too last City lashes
uh last year
yeah we got um we have one Jimmy John's
that's like a couple of miles from here
I've never eaten at it at that one like
I've eaten in other ones but not that
one yeah Jeff yard said the YouTube
channel the company man did a video on
the decline of quizzes yeah I think I
saw that I love company man I watch all
this new [__] oh okay so I was thinking
of Whoppers you're thinking of Whoppers
it's a Milk Dud well like I said they
used to come in a white box that was
smaller
than that
they're chewy
oh okay
I stand corrected yeah well like I said
I never ate those so I didn't know there
used to be a white box of green letters
and there was a couple different flavors
of them
Louie says Whoppers are good yeah
Whoppers are good too they're great in
[__] uh
you [__] up the lighting okay it'll
come back they're great they're great in
vanilla shakes
uh [__] like a Whopper Blizzard from
from [__] Dairy Queen
man those blizzards are so good Snickers
was my favorite but yeah the Oreo ones
are pretty good too
man I can't get the [__] lighting
they're not getting me crazy okay
goobers and raisinets yeah goobers I
remember those yeah I don't like
anything with raisins in it I don't
really like raisins
uh Camp guy said Panda Express just got
big in the last two or three years yeah
they're they're like massive yeah
they're pretty good I like them yeah I
don't mind yeah I don't mind Express
actually
um
let me see
like a milk carton
Trey says I remember that yeah you
remember the milk dudes like a milk
carton they were they were white there
was a white box yeah I remember that but
like I said I never liked those so much
so I didn't really like pay that much
they were kind of like a real chewy
raisinet some of them other ones were
just chocolate or it was not it was
chocolatey caramel that was covered in
chocolate and it was a ball and they
were just chewy it was super good man
when I was a little kid in the 70s we
used to eat them Louis brings up Rolos
Rolos ooh I like Rolos are real good
what about toffee Faye
toffee fade they still have to have them
like I kind of feel like that's
old-timey candy but like I got some yeah
they still got them
um they have them at Walgreens on CBS I
don't know about like anywhere else but
they also sell them in big packages now
they do and it's like I got some like oh
my God these are delicious
I remember when I was a little kid when
they came out I just said he's made them
anymore
but they still got him remember baby
Ruth's yeah yeah you haven't seen Reggie
bars remember Reggie yeah I didn't
remember that was pretty that was pretty
short-lived yeah sure I think you can
still you I heard there's a retro
candies are available they are they are
you gotta well there's a whole yeah
there's like whole um online stores that
because remember I got you remember a
couple years ago or two yeah I bought
you that big huge bags I love saltwater
tap if y'all want to send me a bag of
saltwater I'll sit around get fat
I got him a five pound bag of something
you will [__] my diet I'll come in here
fat as a [__] you'll slow the
six-pack down six months you send me
[__]
saltwater taffy I can't stop eating
tequila if that's it yeah and I'm not
like I like taffy but it's not I'm never
just kind of like ooh I want some Taffy
right now so I think you ate most of the
five pounds what am I like not like not
in a day or anything it was a while one
of my favorite taffies was an old
[__]
vintage candy that's still out there
it's called Abba Zaba and it was a white
yeah
[__] peanut butter I think they still
make that [__] was good dude I think
this don't make those yeah
Louie Says Baby Ruth are awesome yeah
honestly like if it has peanuts in it
I'll eat a Payday bar I like payday bars
yeah I know that's like maybe a
controversial opinion no they're good
yeah I like them Clark remember Clark
bars yeah those are good too chicko
stick
yeah kind of like a Clark Bar but
without the chocolate on it what was the
one that was like [__] did it happen
what was it does it have like
marshmallow or some [__] in there I was
like uh the marshmallow one yeah you
know what I'm talking about with like
the was it dark chocolate on the outside
I think so yeah I didn't eat it because
I was like marshmallow gross but it was
dense marshmallows yeah yeah yeah like
we almost like nougat it was like nougat
what about they had zero bars and Uno
bars remember those yeah yeah they were
real good man I will I will I stand
zeros there's their [__] you can
still find them some yeah like a place
that I used to work every now and then
you'd go down to like the snack machine
like the vending machine and there'd be
zero bars in there not always but
sometimes and I'd be like ooh and I'd
have to get one was kind of like a damn
parallel universe Milky Way it's like a
Milky Way in the center with nougat and
caramel
but I think it had almonds in it and it
was covered in white chocolate yeah
didn't have almond on it I think it had
almonds in it it might or some of them
have it might have I'm not really sure I
think it had chipped almonds in it yeah
maybe I think
and it will because nowadays they have a
lot more candy bars available
um that have white that are white
chocolate like they even have white
chocolate like Reese's yeah cups and
stuff but um which is which are awesome
but back in the day like when I was a
kid like me as a white chocolate loving
[__]
um it was kind of harder to find white
chocolate stuff yeah so zero bars was
kind that was the only like widely
available candy bar that was white
chocolate like now you can get a lot of
stuff in white chocolate versions but
back then you got it I just always
remember like every time it was Easter
and my parents and my grandma and stuff
like that would make like little Easter
baskets for us kids and everything and
it's like I was always the weirdest at
the white chocolate bunny because he
truly remembers man he says yeah they
were like a milk carton sometimes they
have it a Cracker Barrel probably okay
okay this is the red the Reggie Jackson
bar yeah the baseball player yeah he
remembers he says I remember that too so
you still can't find them but under a
different name oh okay all right
the Reggie bar was kind of like a turtle
but that's what we would call it today a
turtle that turtles are real good which
is I love Sarah big dollop of [__]
caramel over some kind of usually uh
pecans and then covered in um chocolate
yeah like it kind of looks like the
pecans are like that like turtle feet
that's why from what I remember I mean I
used to love Reggie bars I think a
Reggie bar was that
I don't know if it had
I'm kind of thinking that it didn't have
nuts I kind of thinking that it was Rice
Krispies and then covered in covered in
chocolate I think it's been a long time
since I've had it I just remember loving
them
I think it was rice crisp
I think it was Rice Krispies I think
and then chocolate over it yeah Tracy
the wrapper looks the same and it has a
ball player on it it's just a different
name okay yeah I think they probably
because they could probably couldn't use
they lost a contract they probably lost
either that or they're like nobody knows
anymore
people don't know who Babe Ruth is all
right
that's true but then you know they
called it Baby Ruth they were just like
I think a lot of people maybe don't
think about it yeah but I think the Baby
Ruth was a rip-off on Babe Ruth I don't
think they had permission
yeah I think remember we saw something
about that yeah I saw something about
that on a documentary and it's like I
think they wanted to name it after him
and he was like nah yeah so they made
their own version but that might be
wrong I think no I don't think that was
a licensed product but they got around
it because legally they could call it
whatever they wanted it wasn't his name
right Baby Ruth right and they're like
what we're not even talking about I'm
not talking about you dude you're only
the [__] most famous athlete going
right now you know I think that was 20s
or 30s I don't remember yeah
Trey said there was some place in
Orlando we get saltwater taffy at when
we would go to Disney when I was a kid
I'm pretty sure that's still there
um I went to Disney World last
October or late September or early
October with my sister and
um they all the candy shops that you
probably remember from back in the day
are still there so you can get all that
stuff and plus more stuff because
they've opened a lot more stuff they
used to have this [__] what was the
name of that they used to have this
candy store
it was a chain of them I forgot what
they were called you guys will remember
you could go in there and just buy candy
by the pound we used to have one in the
mall before I grew up but I don't
remember what it's called you have a big
scoop and you just go into a bin and put
it in there and just weigh it yeah and
they would have all that salt water
taffy there and they'd have them divided
by flavors
and I go in there and get like a [__]
pound of black licorice [__] salt
water taffy I [__] love that [__]
so just a pound of the black licorice
yeah oh yeah why would you want that
because it's good man I used to go to
Baskin Robbins on used to go to Baskin
Robbins 31 flavors ice cream
during
um Halloween and get the black licorice
ice cream it was jet black ice cream and
turn your tongue black [__] loved it
remember that yeah I do remember that
yeah but
I'm not a big fan of like the black I
know black licorice is very divisive you
either really really like it or you
really really don't and the Scandinavian
black licorice is even better man
because it's like it's like uh it's
slightly salty it's like eating [__]
beef jerky it's like eating meat you can
just be like well yeah like a meal you
know it's funny every time like I watch
um welcome to the basement which you
know on YouTube
Matt's wife Tona who runs the camera she
is famously loves black licorice
anything yeah so like every time
somebody sends them like a package like
with movies or whatever because they
were review movies they will always send
like a big thing of like Scandinavian
black licorice because it's like she
loves that [__] it's just great I don't
like I'm not a big it's not terrible
like I'll eat it but it's just not you
just have to have some kind of genetic
it must be because it's like like I said
it's very divisive I don't know why some
people just can't handle it they're like
oh it's terrible it's very divisive but
they're just from the second I tasted it
as a kid I was like oh yeah that's
[__] good
it tends to be like yeah like the same
kind of people like black licorice
usually like that remember that
old-timey like clove gum oh yeah yeah
and that kind of stuff I don't think I
love clove I love all that [__] spicy
kind of yeah
aromatic stuff yeah like I said I don't
hate it it's just not my first pick Trey
says I love black licorice oh yeah
that's right you're right bro you're
very right I'm not like hey I don't I
don't harsh
sambuca and a set all that I don't I
don't harsh anybody else's uzo I just
don't like it but other people do I know
yeah
I don't I don't get all upset about it
it's like ew why would you eat that you
know although even I did I just kind of
just did love it granther said Nick Cave
is playing in Detroit in October come on
up
are you gonna like accommodate me
you wanna fly me out there are you gonna
sugar baby her ass up pay your way
because man I'm like like I said I'm
really bummed out that I never got to
see him live
mm-hmm
Louis said I never liked black licorice
either I'm not I'm not a big
I want some [__] candy man I want I
want chocolate
with like some crunch too like two nuts
in there or something
who said that Louie yeah
come on Louie man you're Hispanic man
[__]
that anise flavor was [__] huge in
Central and South America South America
she was [__] huge Brazil
Uruguay Paraguay Argentina
Chile they [__] love anything uzo
[__]
[__] and a set
[__] anything that's kind of like
that black licorice type flavor they
loved it yeah
it had a lot of liqueurs based on it
I don't remember candy based on it
though
just funny
yeah I mean it's I don't even really
like absence yeah which has that kind of
flavor fake absence yeah I mean you know
what I mean yeah I like the whole like
culture around it and I like the
aesthetic around it but I don't like the
taste of the actual stuff all that much
granther said Tom Steve and granther
will show you the ruins of Detroit yeah
yeah that would be fun maybe we should I
think a lot of the ruins have been
returned I mean October I have I have a
lot of time to like save up for that
yeah we get Sophie to come with us
yeah she's in Michigan he's right there
yeah man we'll have like a whole [__]
let's let's do like a whole road trip up
there yeah no we'd have to fly that's
too far to drive at our age I don't want
to fly
but yeah okay I guess I could it's not
that long a flight I suppose
but still but yeah there's a [__]
[__] to go up there
yeah from Florida yeah
I wonder how long that would be
probably about 10 hours
I've driven to I'm trying to think of
the like the farthest place that I've
driven no no I've driven to Baltimore
before I drove to Baltimore that was 13
hours because yeah it's more because
from Mississippi
because I did this from Mississippi to
Detroit I think was 16 hours it was like
doing a double shift right I remember
thinking well it's like doing a double
and you know at that time that I did it
I was the waiters before I joined the
army I was a waiter at Denny's and I
said I've done many doubles I can do it
just behind the wheel
when you're young yeah when you're older
[__] nah you're like oh my God
you just can't take it you know you're
like oh [__] this [__]
and you better have audiobook
well that would probably I could do it
with that I think
because it's helped a lot like my
commute every day which is an hour each
way
um it's helped a lot by you know now
that I have Spotify and I made my own
playlist and also
sometimes what I'll do is whatever we're
doing the show about that week like I'll
listen to like an audiobook or like a
documentary about it like on the way
home and that actually does uh save some
time because I feel like I'm not wasting
time just sitting in the car you know
what I mean say grab Steve's showing me
his [__] AR-15 builds you do pretty
good man he's getting way into the AR
platform
I need to get a [__] 300 whisper
[__] platform I think it was a 300 or
30 black uh 300 Blackout this is black
it's blackout now I'm gonna get one of
those uppers or build one
all I need is a barrel
I would like a GI style though with a
[__] front blade site and all that
so it looks like an xm177 that'd be
[__] cool
because I gotta I got a can that I could
do that I could probably
well I could either leave it a dummy can
or I could [__] actually probably
register it
yeah I think you know register that
[__] is a suppressor
be pretty neat the thing is this [__]
300 Blackout so expensive that's the
problem right now
I need to go shoot man it's been a long
time since I've been shooting there's
got to be shooting around here all the
time some of our neighbors they probably
they're shooting on their own somebody
is they're shooting off because I hear
gunshots all the time in the State of
Florida if you have more than one acre
you can shoot on your own property I'm
at 0.9 Acres
yeah you're shy of it yeah like 0.8 or
0.9 something point nine yeah and uh
the people across the street they have
[__] almost two acres and I think
that's where they're shooting like those
lots across the street yeah I think
that's about two days because sometimes
it's loud like yeah they're shooting
high-powered rifles near the gunshots
some of it sounds like 762 a lot of it's
[__] five five six
at the old place we were at there was it
was suppressed nine millimeter I could
hear it
we've got our walk we went down this
walking path
and there's a nice farm that had a barn
in it and all kinds of [__] that was
where path kid he lived yeah went down I
was walking Kitty's okay
I was walking down there one time and
heard somebody with a nine millimeter
submachine gun on the other side of that
[__] yeah it was a suppressed nine
mil sub gun
and it's got a distinct sound and I was
like
yep somebody knows what they're doing
somebody's got some good [__] over there
little uh five to seven round bursts
the average person wouldn't know what
that was
sounds like a [__] power tool or
something
I mean you know it's they're not silent
but they're suppressed
I could hear the bullet impacts the
bullet impacts were [__] louder than
the [__]
bullet impacts and the sound of the
action that's most of the sound
yeah granther said the closest uh Nick
Cave is playing to you is Asheville
North Carolina I told you he never comes
to Florida never comes to Florida the
only time that he ever came to Florida
was back in the 90s with Lollapalooza
and it got canceled Florida is in a
strange situation where you can't do a
circuit here
because the state is so funny shape yeah
and and the the cities are in a line
so if you're coming down and you go
through Orlando and then you hit
Jacksonville which is right over the
Georgia border then you have to come
back up it you've already played those
venues so right so it's like a wasted
it's a wasted trip
and it's like how many [__] hours is
that I'm trying to remember like how
long it is like from for example like
Jacksonville to Key West
well [__] like even to Key West from
here is probably six hours yeah maybe
longer yeah I've had people hey you can
go down to Miami [__] man he's far
from here I'm like that's like five
hours away what are you talking yeah
I don't know I don't it might not be
five hours from here I drove to Miami a
couple of times from Daytona which is a
little bit north of here and that was
about five hours so it's like I don't
think people understand like how long
Florida is yeah like it's far like Key
West is far I hadn't even I grew up in
Florida in Daytona Beach I didn't go to
Miami until I was in my late 20s or
early 30s it's far if you go
to say the end of the [__] Panhandle
and all the way down to the [__] keys
that's a California type distance yeah
granther said Key West is three hours
from Miami yeah that's what people don't
it's it's far yeah it's far I've never
even been to Key West I've lived in
Florida most of my life and I've never
been the keys are almost another country
it's far yeah the keys are damn near
another country from our point of view
I mean and that's like going that's like
the Caribbean you're basically going to
the Caribbean basically yeah you'll be
hanging down there with [__] I would
like to go I've heard of pirates I've
I've heard it's really cool down there
yeah but I've never been yeah it's just
like I said it's never I've been to
Miami a couple times which is you know
in uh Fort Lauderdale and stuff but
I just never had cause too and it's just
like God it's like it's a really long
drive it's really long drive
so if I'm gonna drive that far holy [__]
um Louie says furthest I've ever driven
was to Oklahoma City from Los Angeles 30
hours
yeah
I'm trying to think if I've driven
farther but I think the farthest I've
ever driven was
Orlando where I lived at the time to
Baltimore and I think that was I think
that was 13 hours
and it wasn't terrible but you know when
I got into Baltimore it's like it's a
massive City so I was just kind of like
freaking out because you know
uh Trey says Love and Rockets is touring
now too I'm gonna be broke buying
concert concert tickets yeah everybody's
touring this summer
um Larry it all broke from because of
coven Larry they go everywhere
layering creature shows up hey what's up
Trey says that's why a lot of Tours end
in Florida the cure for example last two
shows are Tampa and Miami yeah I kind of
feel like that would be the way to do it
right because then they just go back
home because you can't if you do it in
the middle it's just like you said you
play Jacksonville Orlando Tampa Miami
and then like you have to go all the way
back up and it's hours and hours and
hours and that's like a wasted day
because it's a whole day yeah and then
so you might as well like leave that
till the end
uh Trey said the Cure put the smackdown
on all those High ticket prices yeah and
actually like I'm man good on Robert
Smith for like [__] dropping his nuts
and like yeah stand up to [__]
Ticketmaster I don't know if it's gonna
make any difference but
somebody's got to because man
Ticketmaster though oh shamboa for him
remember that what a rochambea for him
okay [__] uh there's a South Park
episode that had Robert Smith in it oh
okay okay that's been a long time yeah I
didn't remember and the South Park kids
are [__] he's leaving and they're
going bye Robert Smith bye Robert Smith
[__] disintegration is the best album
all that kind of [__] [__] but what
what are the [__] things
yeah yeah because we kissed me it's a
great album okay yeah that's good oh he
played hot hot hot last year yeah so I
was into that um
head on the door there's something about
head on the door you can go back to head
on the door [__] and the top is still
good but um
there's an episode where the the [__]
the South Park characters had been
[__] saying that they were going to
Rochambeau somebody and that means kick
somebody in the balls right to to decide
uh some kind of argument or to make a
decision whoever kicked another dude in
the balls before the other guy could do
it with one argument which is called
Rochambeau right which makes sales well
it
there's just to see where Robert Smith
says I'll Rochambeau for it
[Laughter]
evidently there was some old old-time
boxer who kicked somebody in the nuts
his name was Rochambeau or something I
don't know the backstory but that's what
they were talking about
gruther says K West is a hoot if you can
put up with all the amateur drinkers who
think they're Jimmy Buffett yeah yeah
that's the problem that's what I'm
worried about that's how that happens up
here
yeah well and I'm gonna say like I might
have brought this up before but when I
lived in Tampa I worked at a print shop
and the guy that owned the print shop
was the world's biggest Jimmy Buffett
fan uh to an extent where he played the
same [__] Jimmy Buffett CD every God
damn day is it over or is it okay and
over Jimmy Buffett
isn't it spelled the same it is yeah
yeah Jimmy Buffet
you know how people call Target Tarjay
yeah like to make it sound more classy
than Walmart
[Laughter]
he's all you can eat
ew I don't want to eat [__] that I don't
want to eat any of Jimmy Buffett but
yeah so
so he would play like the same thing and
the weird thing about it was that we
have this other kid that worked there
that was like 18 or some [__]
and for some inexplicable reason he was
also super into Jimmy Buffett he was
like probably the only 18 year old I've
ever met that was like super into Jimmy
Buffett like ridiculously so and while I
was working there and I didn't work
there that long because I've got a
better job but they were like Jimmy
Buffett played in Tampa and they were so
[__] jacked and then they went
together like the dude that owned it and
like this kid that worked there and like
when they got back oh my God if they
were like insufferable all they did for
like weeks and weeks was talk about that
[__] Jimmy Buff Larry's in there
saying that it's rosham Rambo
I don't know it's been a long time since
I've seen that episode I thought it was
Rochambeau but it might have been
rochamber in both it might have been I
haven't seen that I don't know I didn't
even remember they only did that joke
for like a part of a season
I haven't heard him do that yeah I
haven't watched [__] South Park
recently they say it's still funny
yeah I can't believe how long that
shit's been on that's crazy yeah
Louie says uh I saw Depeche Mode back in
93 I think we paid 60 for a decent seat
now those same seats are fifteen hundred
dollars
I saw Depeche Mode in 1990 and I think I
had shitty seeds though I had like
nosebleed seats
um I think they were 30 something if I
remember I was still in high or I was
just out of high school there he goes
now I'm [__] with you I recall the
episode though okay
I think it was roshambo I think
Trey said apparently Robert Smith wanted
that Rue shampoo thing in there you did
deciding an argument by kicking somebody
in the nuts yeah well I guess that would
uh yeah sort it out yeah once you've
kicked somebody in the nuts everybody's
like well whoever kicked the other dude
in the nuts first win one
boom I win
[Laughter]
yeah you have to like submit to him you
have to submit my will yeah
Larry says ooh Depeche Mode Black
Celebration is such a good album
probably my favorite album of theirs to
be honest with you Black Celebration
music for the masses is okay too but
I think although
I don't know man um some great reward is
also pretty awesome I don't know man but
I think Black Celebration I don't know
man [__] over the years
over the years [__] Gary Newman has
challenged Depeche Mode's spot for that
for kind of like dark wave I think Jerry
Newman's [__] is [__]
his his later Shades just got better and
better and it kind of has a Depeche Mode
vibe to it they've worked together
before yeah I think a lot of Depeche
Mode's sound was actually Gary Newman
they played them Gary Newman last night
too yeah
Gary Newman's [__] great man he's
better now than he ever was I mean I
kind of feel like
um at a golf club uh you play my name is
ruin my name is ruin and everybody's
gonna dance to that [__] yeah that's a
[__] great song and it's a good song
and his little daughter's doing the
backup vocals and she's in the [__]
video in the post yeah it's like a
post-apocalyptic like yeah it's cool I
forgot what her name is
um she had a funny goth name but she's
grown now it's funny she's like yeah 20
now but she was because that song you
know that song I Associated like a brand
new song but no that thinks no it's all
six or seven years old now isn't it
and he has he has a beautiful little
daughter and she's [__] she's
gorgeous now
um his wife was [__] great I think
his wife is American wasn't she oh I
don't know she ran I know that she ran
his fan club yeah years before they ever
met and then they started yeah they
started dating
and that she was his number one fan
and it's like it's like not into Annie
Wilkes like misery kind of way no one
film and then like hobbling him yeah no
and evidently she's kind of like
because Newman's got some problems he's
he's got Asperger's yeah yeah and uh
he's a little he's pretty open about
that yeah he's a smart dude though
[__] real smart [__] He's rad like
everybody finds a lot of airplanes and
every um interview I've read with him he
sounds like a really cool dude cool dude
yeah like and um
she uh was the driving [__] force
behind a lot of what he did you know a
lot of women are like this man and
[__] make good secretaries you know
what I mean [__] focus a man you know
is that really what you want to say
well they're good support
you know I mean a lot of those dudes I
would flounder without the organization
that of these women behind them well
that's the thing look it's like an Ozzy
Osbourne Ozzy would have never been
successful without Sharon Sharon kept
him [__] working well the thing about
it is that a lot of people not not just
dudes but like a lot of people that are
talented in a particular area yeah
they're kind of scatterbrained yeah
because creativity and organizational
skills don't always go together in the
same person yeah you know what I mean so
you kind of do need that somebody to
like kind of get your [__] tight and
like get all your [__] together and the
thing with the thing with Newman is that
Newman because he he had Asperger's he
was he was rude uh he didn't mean to be
rude it's just that he was very honest
so honest that it would piss people off
right
and uh and he didn't know what he should
sound like he was trying to please the
audience too much or or who he thought
the audience was
he needed to be told who his really fan
who his fans really were
so he'd stop [__] fake attempts at
metal and [__] fake attempts at New
Wave and he he was dark wave kind of
industrial goth that that's who who his
fans were and she kept him focused on
that man
yeah I mean play to your fan base I mean
if that's what you want to do like you
know what I mean right he would never be
another pop star again because pop moves
too quickly they can't make a career off
that for very long there's no stake
power you have to have a fan base and so
she kept him on target with the fan base
so he just started sounding more and
more like him like himself like he
should have sounded his writing his
lyrics is [__] great man [__]
listen to the song [__] dead Heaven
it's an older song
90s I think oh yeah mid 90s late 90s
man
that's just some [__] Wicked [__]
that he's saying in there about how it's
super depressing but a real artistic
real pretty the way it's it's written
and it kind of sounds like a Depeche
Mode song because he was involved with
Depeche Mode he's also involved with
Nine Inch Nails yeah so a lot of what
you know of Nine Inch Nails that sound
that's Gary Newman
Larry said [__] yeah I saw Gary Newman a
few years ago he was all industrial
sounding like and like nin bib Vibes but
better yeah yeah I mean Gary Newman like
preceded Nine Inch Nails yeah
sound actually was because Newman's
influence he was right he did a lot of
the engineering on those albums and a
lot of the a lot of the direction
so uh no [__] Newman's the [__] I'm
always kind of like a big fan more of I
know that there's kind of this whole pop
like everybody wants to make millions of
dollars and everything like that which I
get it you know I mean it's nice to have
millions of dollars but to do that you
usually have to just water your [__]
down so it's like not really you anymore
because you have to like appeal to
everybody so I kind of feel like
somebody like Gary Newman who had a huge
like success in the early 80s as a kid
right when he was still really young and
I just kind of feel like don't keep
chasing that it's like who likes your
[__] like I said like Goths like your
[__] yeah industrial people like like so
cater to that I mean if that's what you
want to do then that's probably the best
because you're gonna have like a solid
loyal fan base you're not gonna make
millions of dollars maybe but you could
make a living at it he's an old man now
he's in his 60s motherfucker's still on
the top of his game he's [__] great
we saw him um when did we see him
that was from Firestone and yeah
2013 2014. yeah it was a few years back
but like that yeah that was a future
that was a great [__] joke and he
went through classic stuff of the 80s
and then into the newer stuff so he so
he covered all bases it was a great show
great show
um another another band that I saw that
was [__] great at that same place
Firestone about a year before maybe six
months before nitzer EB they were
[__] great live I was just I saw them
opening for Depeche Mode I didn't have a
[__] bad ass man [__] life and it
was a low budget show
but they just have [__] a magnetism
to them and their sound
in 1990s so I don't know I haven't seen
them recently so I don't know what they
look like but I was I was they're in
good shape yeah yeah they're in very
good shape and that lead singer was
[__] shredded running around [__]
shirtless his real militant it's
extremely militant and they were [__]
projecting all these images of [__]
you know kind of socialist or national
socialist imagery of [__] you know
yeah that's kind of this looking [__]
yeah that's [__] kind of there is
yeah like sickles and Hammers and
[__] gears and
but really cool really cool
and it's just and it's not political
it's not what they're talking about
they're just showing imagery based upon
power now they're very power and
totalitarianism they're trying to turn
that into like an art you know
and you got to admit man totalitarian
societies had [__] great art in a
certain way it was great problem yeah I
really like visceral propaganda from an
aesthetic standpoint yeah I'm really
into like the Soviet uh aesthetic and
like all that artwork like that
propaganda artwork they did like I think
that's really beautiful it looked good
it was all Art Deco kind of looking and
right cartoons simplistic I like that
look and like a lot of the 80s like New
Wave kind of postponed because they kind
of like um they use that a lot yeah and
the Germans you know the Germans in that
same area were caught in the same era
were copying and trying to respond to
Soviet propaganda
because they they recognize the power
they were saying we got to have
something like that better though
so
all your totalitarian societies have to
have fun well powerful Vision power
visuals because visuals are I mean that
gets like right into your lizard brain
right it's like nothing you have to
think about you just like see something
and you're like yeah that's true right
that's exactly that's true so that's why
they're trying to like distill
everything down so they can control
people's minds better but like I said
just from an aesthetic point of view I
like that look it's the ultimate form of
advertising right that's all there is
propaganda is advertising same [__]
Larry says uh do you have you ever heard
of the band suicide oh yeah I have some
of their songs on my uh Spotify playlist
matter of fact uh pre-punk even one guy
with an organ drum machine fuzz out and
a singer with Echo pedal style vocals
like their early industrial 70s yeah I'm
really into like my probably I don't
know if somebody asked me like my
favorite genre I'm just gonna say
post-punk because that covers a lot of
stuff that I like but I like a lot of
pre or Proto punk as well so I like you
know suicide the Stooges uh you know
Velvet Underground all that kind of
stuff
um I'm into all that kind of MC5 uh I
like all that kind of stuff too but yeah
I have some suicide songs in my not a
lot I probably should know more about it
but I you know I do have some of their
stuff on my Spotify
Depeche Mode is playing the Forum here
in LA and floor seats are going for wait
thirteen thousand dollars or thirteen
hundred dollars thirteen thousand that
seems a little steep uh for that price
Dave Gahan better sign everything you
want I mean for thirteen thousand
dollars Dave Gahan better come to my
house and have sex with me and cook me
food and [__] like that because Jesus
Christ thirteen thousand dollars
that's like half a Year's wages Come On
Dave but you know what I mean but like I
said I like look I love Depeche Mode I
do
but I saw them I saw them in 1990 when
they were still like at their Peak and I
kind of feel like
I don't want to see them that bad now
there's really not that many bands
now that I haven't seen
in more in their Heyday so it's like
they it would really have to be like I
would pay a lot probably to see Nick
Cave just because I never got to
um you know even though he's older now
but
other than that like most of the bands
that I wanted to see I've seen and I saw
them like at their prime or a little bit
past their Prime so I kind of feel like
now I was just like me
six hundred dollars per ticket yeah no
thanks
I'll skip that like I can just like
watch their old videos and like I just
don't have the money I just don't have
the money I kind of feel like that's the
only like Nick Cave I would pay a lot to
see him just because I never got to and
I was like that's like the one thing
that I wanted to kick off my bucket list
I'm still mad that I never got to see
the fall and it's like now I never will
obviously because Marky Smith died like
a couple years ago and I never got to
see them I think the closest they ever
came to Florida was Atlanta and I
couldn't get up there to see them like
the last tour that they did through
there
so that kind of bums me out then I never
got to see him before he died but you
know what I mean what are you gonna do
you're making a stripper days for me
making ups for Bernie
banana daiquiri Haze my stripper name
would be Tom the bomb man the bomb is it
that well I don't know that's a little
basic don't you think gotta be Basics
memorable
um
I'd come up with some [__]
Larry said the fall never got bad too
some of their best stuff was their later
stuff yeah I agree they had to come to
hear about the fall over and over again
I know so the thing about the fall that
was so cool and I think that um one of
the best things that I ever read about
them and I think it was John peel that
said this about them he said they're
always different but they're always the
same and it's like it's really really
hard to explain because every album
because they did like a lot that oh my
God they had so many albums here but
what do you put out like two or three
albums a year or something like that
it's like some ridiculous number
like I couldn't even keep up I have a
lot of their [__] but like I still
couldn't keep up with all their stuff
but the thing about it was that they
were they always he was always doing
something different
like all their albums sounded different
but you could still tell it was them and
they never stopped I mean I say them
it's like it was mostly him but like
with rotating band members but that I
kind of feel like that's a real Hallmark
of like kind of artistic genius because
every single [__] even when he was
getting old and [__] like that and he
was you know whatever but he would put
out new [__] and be like man this is
awesome too like he was always kind of
like experimenting with different stuff
you could still tell it was them but it
sounded different from their old stuff
but you could still tell it was them and
I was like I think that's kind of
the the peak of like artistic as far as
like musical stuff goes because it's
hard to do that I kind of feel like a
lot of bands fall into a rut where it's
just kind of like well we're gonna try
and do new [__] but we're like not even
like we were like we lost our Identity
or we're just gonna do the same [__]
over and over but the fall they really
he really kept it on a on a really good
balance between you know I'm staying
with the [__] that I do but it's like
I'm experimenting with all these other
things and I think he was really
successful at doing that because some of
their new [__] was like really good too
I thought
uh Larry said yeah man the word Legend
gets tossed around a lot but Markie
Smith was one he was for sure he was for
sure and like I said that bums me out so
much that I didn't get to see them live
like before before he died I got to see
Lux interior before he died I did too so
I'm in [__] Boston he's [__] it
was a great show The Cramps they were
[__] great I [__] love the games
did they uh I'm really glad that our
show I saw them like yeah I saw them I
think like two years before he died yeah
I think and he was great man
poison ivy his wife [__] great great
show it's like she's still around I
think yeah satisfied another one I
[__] give him a lot of credit
a [__] with him okay because I respect
him Larry says I [__] love the cramps
I do yeah yeah cramps uh Glenn Danzig
Glenn Dad's this [__] great life even
though he looks [__] up now but last
time I just [__] wait when he looked
good he [__] up because he [__]
himself up man he didn't know what he
was doing with [__] anabolics
I mean definitely he did something wrong
was it run a testosterone base or
something [__] did something weird
with [__] growth hormones his face is
not right
that's something with
I don't know who he was listening to
but
because you know he wasn't he was jacked
you know what I mean but that was
probably an angel alone probably and um
he couldn't maintain that for some
reason he didn't know what he was doing
um
but I'll tell you what man uh
you can knock him out you can you can
[__] make fun of him for being a
Satanist in a world of atheists you know
what I mean you could say all kinds of
[__] about Glenn Glenn could [__]
sing he could write bad ass [__] live he
was [__] fantastic fantastic I
[__] was up front of the [__]
Venus de Milo [__] Boston [__]
song was in the front row next to me
were three Japanese schoolgirls being
crushed by the [__] crowd they were
in the 50s skirts and [__] and
everything to see Glenn Danzig they were
probably Tufts University students
[__] reached out and touched danzig's
[__] Boot and [__] satanic energy
went into me and that's when I became
the Tom that you know
it was like spiritual for the dancing
did it dancing dancing and Steven Seagal
you never touched Steven Seagal though
dude no no just mine to mine it was mine
to mine I [__] I gave you an Asian
experience yeah he gave you an Asian
experience hahaha
let's see how you go yeah I [__] with
them both but there's a big difference
all right
the Seagal's [__] and he's lying uh
[__] dads that could deliver
oh yeah hell yeah I mean at least Danzig
is like yeah talented yeah he was good
he was good
that's mean but you know what I mean
yeah uh Larry said 70 stuff was so good
too like talking about the fall
um yeah I mean to be honest like I love
their new [__] too but I think my
favorite
period of them was probably like
early 70s to late 80s I think is like my
best but I liked like some [__] like
after that too but it's like that's
that's still like the [__] that I get
back to all the time there's Larry's in
their left that's my backstory yes my
backstory almost and I'm sticking to it
right
he's also like amazed that we saw the
cramps I [__] love the cramps oh yeah
yeah no waves yeah
separate in two different yeah yeah
[Music]
I can't remember what year it was what
year did Lex interior die oh [__]
he was like he was pretty young but I
kind of feel like I saw them I think it
was only a year or two before he died
and he was like man he just he looked
[__] great he had like that red he's
like still like [__] all skinny and
[__] and he had like that red [__]
shredded snake skin yeah he was like
climbing all over the [__] stage he
was like in really good he's a real
character I think he was in his 40s or
50s when I saw him that was in the 90s
96 97. yeah I think I saw him a little
bit later than that but it's like I
don't remember when he died but it was a
couple of mid 40s late 40s or something
he was [__] uh on stage live he was a
force to be reckoned with man
the only thing close to that would have
been Iggy Pop
yeah
it's just that Charisma right yeah it's
just kind of like [__] off the
[__] chain they were so [__] good
man I don't even remember like where the
[__] did I see them Visage no
The Edge overall best show I've ever saw
live
I think it was 1987.
Pine Knob theater
grandpars knows the theater was with
Steve Rouse of high school [__] bro
and we saw
the cult opening up for Billy Idol
Whiplash smile to her and that was a
great show [__] the cult knocked it
out of the park and then Billy Idol came
out and that and Billy Idol was the best
live performance I'd ever seen to this
day Billy Idol [__] he was at
the height of his [__] power
that show is [__] phenomenal
he was great
I mean Michael Jackson level [__]
greatness with the show how it went
and then he delivered
and [__] the crowd went [__] crazy
he was great live
especially when he was young he was
still young at that time yeah because
that was a while back a long time but he
was [__] young and he just [__]
killed
[__] killed the audience [__]
great
I was impressed
to this day I'm still impressed and he
wasn't no you know what I mean he he's
he was popular
but he didn't really have a rep like
that not with and that was more like
from the metal scene you know he didn't
have a rep with a metal scene no he was
[__] on and you know and I think he
was a little too punk rock
to meddle for the
for the pop scene even though he was pop
really yeah he got like huge success in
the you know in in the early 80s yeah
with the kind of on the back of the new
wave kind of thing right and like but
Gen X was good too it's like I feel like
a lot of people don't go back Gen X was
good yeah because a lot of the songs
that he popularized later were
dancing myself right
but uh he was great live great live
performers a tremendous Charisma
tremendous
and that dude was good looking super
good looking if you saw him in person
nah
and he held out for a long time he still
looks pretty good but he was just very
magnetic
Larry says early Misfits are cool don't
dig the later stuff yeah I can see that
uh early U2 was pretty cool I like The
Chameleons too oh man yeah I love the
Camille [__] great but yeah like you
two I like YouTube pre
88. now YouTube had some cousins that
were in a band called virgin prunes they
were [__] great one of their cousins
one of their cousins wasn't at the edges
cousin I think it was the edge cousins I
can't remember yeah I don't think it was
bottles there are some there were some
Irish [__] but uh yeah you want
to check out the Virgin princess
they were real good I love the version
right yeah but yeah yeah they're really
good too they were part of that they
were part of that of that whole kind of
like Gothic Neo Pagan Neo folk type with
rock mix they were good like with Death
in June and
um you know [__] Boyd rice and
current 93 David Tibet and I [__]
love those bands too
I got some current 93 on my Spotify
I told him it's like I finally found
time to
curate my own Spotify list which at
present is 28 hours long yeah yeah we
were sitting there and [__] Death in
June came on [__] uh
fall and fall and fall and I told him I
was like well we were listening we were
going to go to the club last night
because like a lot of the [__] I put a
bunch of [__] on there that like he
probably doesn't like so I have to skip
over some stuff but it's like
he was like like songs would come on
he's like man this is a good song too
I'm like hey yeah I made this playlist
though right it's like it rocks if I do
say so myself so you know what I mean
there he's tripped out you guys got
great love all the bands mentioned yeah
we know what we're doing we're not just
[__] random Youtube [__] we
got histories bro
no but I've been doing this [__] since
1983. and it's not just the goth and
metal scene I liked a lot of other [__]
I mean there was there was [__] early
rap that I was big into as big into
Public Enemy uh there's a rare one that
I was experimental rap band called New
Kingdom that I [__] really loved yeah
I remember you telling me new kingdom
was [__] great that was uh
um uh [__] there's an album out there
called Mexico or bust you guys need to
check that out it's kind of like Cypress
Hill uh kind of like that but it was
about black dudes in the desert going to
[__] Mexico and [__] doing a
strange [__] on the border or driving
around in [__] Mad Max style vehicles
and it's just it was a great exp It was
a commercial failure but artistically
new kingdom was [__] great man and
those guys are all in obscurity now okay
we're gone which is sad sad
sad but that was southwest
desert rap
really good which I feel like you don't
see much
and they were they were mixing in Jimi
Hendrix type [__] Vibes and they
would talk about Jimi Hendrix and then
they would just talk about a lot of
things you know they were like that was
not
um
would have not really been considered
cool in the [__] rap world you know
what I mean I mean now it would be no it
would be back then yeah
it was experimental
Louis said uh I saw Bowie and Nine Inch
Nails in 95 best concert I've ever
attended oh I remember when that tour
was going around I didn't get to it I've
seen for some reason only one time on
purpose but I've seen Nine Inch Nails
probably well I was gonna say like more
than any other artist no that's not true
I've seen Peter Peter Murphy more than
any but other artist but Nine Inch Nails
I saw them once on purpose like they
were the headliner and then the rest of
the time I just saw them kind of
accidentally because they were opening
for someone else or they were on like a
you know like Lollapalooza or something
like that so I've seen them like [__]
five times Without Really meaning to
like one time I met two but the other
time I think it was when I saw them when
they were headlining it was Nine Inch
Nails and hit the [__] open for them I'm
trying to remember
I'll probably remember in a minute uh
yeah Larry said you guys got great
chased in music love all these bands
mentioned I'm 28 went back to find all
these bands see that's
that's so [__] awesome to me well
because I mean I did that too like when
I was a kid
you know in the early 80s like I was
really into like post-punk and new wave
and stuff like that but my dad was
really into like the Beatles and the
doors and [__] like that and so I got
really into that too because I'm like oh
this shit's good too and then when I got
into 80s new wave and Post Punk and they
would bring up a lot of their influences
like it's like oh we're influenced by
The Velvet Underground of the Stooges or
something like that so I went back and
listened to that like as a teenager too
so it's kind of like I like that people
are still doing that nowadays you know
what I mean like the bands that I liked
because I was so into music I was like
well what are the you know what are
these musicians like where are their
influences coming from because I want to
listen to that too because I want to
know more about it so that's kind of
what I did that's how I got into you
know Stooges and MC5 and Velvet
Underground and stuff like that because
a lot of the bands that I liked like
Bauhaus and stuff like that were you
know citing that as influences so I went
back and listened to that too and like I
said I grew up in a household with a lot
of music because my dad was really into
music as well and he was really into 60s
stuff like I said it was a huge huge
Beatles fan I'm and I'm still a huge
Beetle fan as well and he was like into
the doors The Kinks You Know Rolling
Stone stuff like that so I listen to all
that stuff growing up like as a little
kid
um Larry says my best friend's mom saw
Hendricks and the stones on the same
bill I mean that must have been [__]
amazing I Love Jimi Hendrix actually
Jimi Hendrix is awesome uh Louis said I
like pre-90s you do yeah I kind of feel
like after the 90s well I kind of like
pre-90s everybody
I don't think it's any surprise like
anybody I don't know what it is but the
90s you'd think that it would have been
like my kind of formative decade because
that was the I graduated from high
school in 1990 and so like then I was
going to college and stuff like that and
I got into some music like in the early
90s but I didn't like it as much it just
it seemed like especially after I mean
if you're around at the time like
especially after like Nirvana got really
big like in 91 or whenever that was and
then all of a sudden like alt rock or
like alternative music was like super
huge and like everybody was getting into
it and like and then it just kind of
became more like corporate and slick and
it's just like now everybody sounds like
Pearl Jam and it's just like I was just
like not into it I didn't like it like
there were some good goth music in the
90s like I like a lot of 90s goth bands
still like Corpus delicti and uh the
Shroud and Rosetta Stone and [__] like
that so there was like a lot of good
stuff going on like underground still
but I don't know like the 90s just
seemed like a creative void as far as
good music went there's a lot of good
music from the 90s just like there's a
lot of good movies from the 90s and I
always like piss and moan about oh no
but obviously there was a lot but it
just wasn't the same I don't know it
wasn't the same
Larry says my favorite bands are 13th
floor elevators that's cool like Rocky
Erickson uh seed Stooges suicide the
Damned the fall Joy Division specimen
than the usual British Invasion stuff
yeah specimen's awesome too I have a
bunch of their stuff on my uh it's
basement three I remember them I
remember them Louie's talking about
Scott
yeah remember the Bostons yeah yeah I
like the mighty buddy actually
I like a lot of Skies like my favorite
well my my sister
who's seven years younger than me but
she's real into
um or she I don't know about now but she
was like real into I think she still is
but she was real into
um that kind of thing like she really
really like Scott and like that kind of
like Irish flavored Punk and she likes
all that kind of stuff yeah the British
God was good too what was the one we
were just listening we just heard the
other night specials the specials was
the specials you know all the clubs have
been shut down when the specials yeah
yeah it goes yeah yeah let's go ghost
town ghost town yeah yeah
some good [__] yeah I like some Sky well
like I said that's British dudes with
[__] Jamaican guys making music
that's the [__] see that's what I
love about Post Punk and I don't know if
that would ever happen again because
that was kind of like well that was kind
of like a um you know a characteristic
of the time yeah because of the time
anyways also do-it-yourself stuff they
were these guys hanging out yeah and it
was just kind of and they were kind of
like forging new they were combining
genres that hadn't been combined
previously which was kind of like a big
and like I said now everybody like now
it's not a big deal because everybody's
combined everything with everything to
an American that sounds strange what the
[__] did Jamaicans doing hanging out
with [__] British guys people did a
lot of Americans don't realize that
[__] Jamaica is part of the British
Empire okay I wouldn't it's it's a
satellite country all right kind of like
our version of Puerto Rico so
so uh they travel between the the two
islands
and the two sounds [__] Blended and
Jamaica had a [__] badass Street
sound where they were [__]
uh making music on the streets and
selling booze and [__] little
um Jamaican
cities and neighborhoods you know guys
would open up our own club just by
putting a record player out [__]
selling Hooch you know yeah and uh then
bands would appear
and they would make reggae you know well
Brock and reggae started to blend in
England those guys would go up to
England and they'd [__] hang out and
then start a band
so a lot of those early 80s British ska
bands you know you look and half the
members are black you're like wait I
didn't know they have black people in
England yeah they got black people but a
lot of a lot of those particular guys in
that band were from Jamaica
which that's kind of a [__]
interesting cross breed inside of a band
that you have and the [__] sound was
great man it was British
basically you're dealing with [__]
kind of is there an American equivalent
to that yeah well rock and roll would be
would be an American which is [__] um
white music and Mississippi delta blues
became pretty much rock and roll so it'd
be like it was like that
uh it is yeah it is kind of like a combo
I don't know if people think of it like
that but that's what that's what that
would be an analogy rock and roll
Mississippi delta blues and just
regularly because remember like back
back when rock and roll was becoming
like popular like in the 50s or whatever
um a lot of uh really uptight white
people were like freaked out about it
because they were like they thought
that's like black music yeah well this
is the thing man [__] there's been
this um Public Enemy
did a song I remember the name of which
one it was
yeah
it said that Elvis was racist did it
that wasn't true
Elvis grew up in a predominantly black
area of Mississippi
and uh went to black churches and sang
black gospel music and I was friends
with uh James Brown and
but there was like rumors that he was
these rumors are modern they're not old
rumors they're modern rumors that he was
some kind of racist man the clan hated
for hated Elvis Presley I kind of feel
yeah they said that he was basically
being black yeah you know and that he
was bringing black music to white people
and that that was a bad thing now I can
understand like how people might
um like black people might be mad at him
for like co-opting their music and like
you know but other than like he
personally was not racist now I don't
think and um well the thing is is that
you have to look at it at the time black
artists of the time weren't bad at him
they [__] loved him they had friend
they were friends with him James Brown
and a lot of other artists black artists
[__] they liked Elvis
um
there's there's videos about it
um on YouTube about that Elvis wasn't
racist and it's most of it is
testimony of black people that knew him
of the time and other artists and said
well he really was
he was very much like
a 1950s to 1970s
version of Eminem a lot like Eminem
that's a good analogy you don't hear
anybody saying the M M's racist he was
like that he was just
took a black concept and rebooted it and
innovated it I mean and that was kind of
what he grew up with what he liked yeah
it wasn't fake
yeah like he wasn't just co-opting it
because he's like oh I'm gonna make like
mad [__] cash no on this no he just
liked that yeah uh black blues players
in Mississippi taught him how to play
guitar he was from dirt poor background
and that was who he hung out with he
taught him how to play a guitar that was
the sound he grew up with
now um
black Witnesses of the time an artist
said that it uh one of the what I can't
remember which guy said it
he says you have to understand that that
brother was good looking
that had a lot to do with it and he
brought that music to the mainstream a
lot of it was because how how handsome
he was well yeah and and on the back of
that that [__] broke down a lot of
barriers for other black artists to come
through yeah which in a way like was
probably a big help yes
and I can see getting mad because it's
like well they should have been able to
get famous like on their own thing but
it's like Society just wasn't uh weren't
ready for that and you have to have it
was sad but for the mainstream you had
to have a [__] good salesman for that
because that [__] was subversive and he
was good looking enough to sell that to
the mainstream the [__] girls went
crazy for and that's where the money was
at the time and he brought that [__]
mainstream now at the time of his death
he was working on a working on a uh some
kind of a a project with uh James Brown
who he was friends with James Brown they
were both Southern Republicans which a
lot of people don't realize which that
was a different scene back then
uh and evidently [__] James Brown
lost it at [__] Elvis's funeral you
know they gave him time alone with the
body and all that but uh and then Brown
went on to live for a long time okay
yeah
and uh he was a troublemaker but [__]
all those dudes were all those dudes
were [__] crazy you know what I mean
they were cool but they were crazy you
know well you kind of have to be a
little bit Yeah to be like Dot and brown
was the [__] man [__] I liked James
Brown Yeah his material was [__]
really good his [__] stage present
was [__] his stage presence his stage
Act was [__] great I like a lot of
that [__] he ran a tight like early rock
and roll I love that [__] he ran a tight
ship too if you were gonna be on his
[__] team you had to dress and dance
perfectly you had to be your music had
to be spot on he did not tolerate
um
uh low standards he did not tell he was
a [__] very high standard individual
Larry says uh yeah punk didn't have a
sound back in the day it was more uh an
ethic an ethic of DIY attitude now
people think Punk is like the Mohawks
and stuff and then he said yeah there
was a huge Jamaican influence in the
punk scene in London in the 70s a lot of
those punks were also listening to
reggae yeah and I think that's what a
lot of people don't realize is that
prior to I kind of feel like prior to
the early 90s
um anything that had to do with like
alternative type of music that wasn't
mainstream it all just got lumped
together so a lot of those people and I
experienced this myself like growing up
in the 80s is that if you were into
anything that wasn't mainstream pop
music like if you were into goth or if
you're into Punk or if you were into
reggae or if you're into like anything
that was like you know not mainstream
you all just kind of hung out together
yeah so I can and I kind of feel like
that was you didn't really have any like
see like subcultures or it was just all
one big subculture because you were all
just like the weirdos that weren't like
those people so you all just hung out
together so I kind of feel like there
was a lot of cross-pollination of genres
that was going on that maybe wouldn't
happen nowadays Crafters called it the
the lyric came from about Elvis being a
racist came from a song called Fight the
Power which is a [__] great song
great video too
when [__] and I said that Elvis was a
straight up racist and all kinds of [__]
but it was look Chuck D came out he
wrote that like he says no I just kind
of made that up and that's really where
that started right and he said no I just
kind of made that up actually yeah like
I said I don't think him is like I don't
I don't begrudge people being mad that
he popularized music that it's like
should have been popularized like on its
own merits okay I like I can understand
being mad about that but it's not
Elvis's fault really that's kind of like
the culture's fault at large yeah more
than else somebody had to sell it it was
a new idea and it's like I don't really
feel a new idea I mean Elvis seemed like
a nice dude to be honest um and he
didn't really seem to be like wanting to
exploit anybody or anything like that he
just really seemed like that was the
music he grew up with that was the music
that he loved even like later on he went
straight gospel pretty much yeah that's
what he was into I was I'm a big fan of
Elvis I was never really a big fan of
his music even though [__] it was I
think his best song was If I Can Dream I
think is the name which is about racial
holy [__] watch that [__] on YouTube
it's amazing yeah it's amazing and and
it's kind of about that's a great song
he's talking about healing the wounds
between north and south and white and
black all right and [__] because this
is during the Civil Rights Movement it
was his comeback
show that was televised called if I
could dream and [__] that's really I
think his best work even though he did a
lot of good work but I think that's his
best offer yeah I'm a huge fan Elvis I
was never really a huge fan of his music
because really it was
it's gospel I don't mind guys
I'm just not a big fan of gospel he
loved gospel and and it's it's it's it's
Southern
Baptist black gospel that's what he's
that's what he's that's what he's
singing which I was I mean it's good
there's something old lady-ish to me old
ladies
associated with the old ladies when I
was a little kid listened to that I get
that yeah but I kind of feel like now
because I'm just gonna say just from a
personal standpoint I'm on like I said I
was trying to work yeah it was yesterday
the day before and my Spotify playlist I
have um if you know like Nick Cave did a
song called the witness song which kind
of said which was on um The Good Son
which I think was 1990 I want to say and
it sounds like a gospel song like and he
sounds because he does a lot of like
kind of gospel flavored [__] but I like
that [__] though that new movie that
came out we saw was [__] excellent
what about Elvis what was the name of
that one we saw it was just called Elvis
it is called Elvis yeah but the Basler
men one yeah same guy who did [__]
Romeo and Juliet and the [__] uh
Moulin Rouge he did that one about him
and I want to see Moulin Rouge again
yeah I love that [__] see that new
Elvis movie and uh it's pretty accurate
pretty accurate and it's it's told in
the fast I mean it's ramped up it's
fast-paced it's fast
he's gonna have glitter and [__] it's
got to be fun but yeah I liked it I
thought and then the other movie I would
recommend about Elvis would be like
Elvis and Nixon where it's about Elvis's
a [__] hilarious [__] it's Michael
Shannon's in there I don't watch
anything Michael Shannon and he looks
like I like Elvis I love that dude and
he looks nothing like Elvis but he Nails
it okay he's channeling channels
it's about Elvis's secret mission to go
[__] talk to Nixon and become a
secret agent all right that's how crazy
Elvis was and you don't know how
whatever was it was I was just trying to
get the badge or did he really want to
be a secret agent I kind of feel like
it's probably the second thing I think
he really wanted to be a secret agent he
was on a lot of [__] at that time yeah
goes to the warehouse him in the Memphis
mob are all packing 1911s and [__] and
he goes you carrying any webs oh yeah
we're all carrying [__]
[__]
Chrome plated [__]
inlaid [__] inlaid grip [__] 1911s
and [__] he gives [__] President
Nixon a [__] commemorative model
[__] 1911 45 Auto for his service in
Korea and [__] right before eating all
his Eminence eating all his M M's
may be the president but you haven't
understand I'm a king
I was like nice I like that yeah and
evidently it's all true compared to
Elvis's friend said yeah that's what he
did he was tried doing karate for the
president
that would be so good because well like
I said Michael Shannon I will watch that
[__] in anything I love Michael Shannon
yeah it's great it's a great movie I
think my favorite Michael Shannon movie
that I've ever seen is bug but
because he plays like a completely crazy
person in that you probably like that
movie actually okay it's from the when
was that from 90s or early 2000s I can't
remember
um
Larry says yeah I'm pretty sure Elvis
was famous for doing stuff like refusing
to play without his black backup singers
whenever places tried to get get them
not to come yeah yeah yeah he yeah he
was really like I said I would never
like accuse Elvis himself of being
racist like I said I think the culture
at large was for sure and I think that
was kind of where the problem yeah
Louie's wrong he said well he didn't
speak out against right no he did he did
he did it but he had to do it in the
[__] in in the ways of the 50s he
didn't think he he's like no rock and
roll should should be listened to
everybody you know and uh no he he was
um what I'm trying to think
is there evidence to him speaking out
against it I think there is I'd have to
look it up yeah of course there is
because he would go on tour with black
artists as backup singers
well that's what that's right and then
some people he would show up to a
theater and they said well you can't
have black people in our theater and he
was like oh well no [__] that if you
know if it would be like black female
backup singers and she can't come in I
ain't playing you know and then and he
would break them of that
so no he didn't he didn't buy any of
that [__]
no which is like [__] crazy to think
about nowadays yeah that's crazy
well there was segregation happening
yeah I know yeah yeah I know I wasn't
alive during that time but I was I mean
I was born in the 70s so I kind of
remember like a little bit of the
leftover of that you know what I mean
holy [__] no but no he he fought against
that wherever he went
Louis says my junior high girlfriend was
in to Scott and everyone thought she was
goth completely different genre
yeah I don't really here's the weird
thing okay so like I was at work the
other day
um a couple weeks back
and somebody I think there was like a um
there was some music on that was
somebody somewhere like some YouTube
channel
it's a band I don't know what they're
called but they do like country like way
country music versions of like
alternative [__] from the 90s so it's
like Blink 182 like [__] like that
and somebody at work said something like
it's like oh it's like country versions
of goth songs I'm like you really think
God's listen to Blink 182. what the [__]
it's like that is totally not even close
to goth music and it's just but it just
goes to show that and you know I don't
blame people like they don't know like
they you know if it's not something that
you're into you don't realize like all
the nuances and stuff but it's just kind
of like there's a whole other world of
like uh Nuance out there about goth
music and it's like there's goth has
like a billion different subgenres that
like people are into and some people
like this sub genre and not so much that
subgenre so it's just kind of it's just
like anything else if you don't know
anything about it then it seems
um you know it seems kind of
just all one thing but it's really
really not it's really not
um Scott and Goth are two completely
different things and I'm not saying that
some Goths don't like Scott because I'm
a goth and I like Ska but it's you know
it's not my favorite thing but like if
it comes on I'm like yeah I'm into this
but it's not
it's really not the same thing and it's
really not even the same crowd I don't
know about nowadays but back in the old
days that was like kind of two different
crowds they hung out together but it
wasn't really the same thing
do your co-workers know your goth any
judgers
um no everybody where I work seems like
pretty nice
um they know what kind of music I listen
to you but I don't they don't seem like
super super interested so I'm just kind
of like I just keep it to myself you
know what I mean which is what I usually
do I don't
um
I don't like hide my weirdness but I
also don't like broadcasted either if
that's
if that makes any sense you know what I
mean and I'm not gonna
we have a guy where I work that he's
kind of like the DJ
so he just like plays music and he
usually plays he'll play like a lot of
different genres so sometimes it'll be
classical which is fine with me
um sometimes it'll be country which is
not so much fine with me because holy
[__] that shit's annoying um all of it
sounds like a parody of country music
but I was like oh you're serious okay
but you know what I mean so it's all
like that uh or it's just like generic
EDM like kind of dance music which
whatever it's you know it's not great
but I can tune it out so but if they ask
me it's like oh play your music all day
I don't think I would
because that's my [__] I don't want
y'all like judging so
I'm just gonna listen to that [__] in my
car and I don't want anybody complaining
about it you know what I mean it's that
kind of thing
we're talking about the differences
between goth and Scott
like I said the thing about all the
alternative and like I said I don't know
how [__] Works nowadays because it's
probably different
because now everybody like has access to
everything at all times so I feel like
the distinctions between the subgenres
have largely dissolved or become like a
lot more nebulous but back in the old
days I kind of feel like I knew some
people that were really into Punk and
sky and stuff like that and then like
people that were super super a little
like Gotham industrial and it's like
they didn't listen to a lot of the same
music but there was like a little bit of
overlap you know what I mean because I
kind of feel like golf industrial people
it's like oh we like the specials or are
we like the Damned or we well I don't
know the Damned is a bad example but I
mean we like like just like punk rock or
whatever so it's just kind of like
so you hung out together and you could
find some common ground because when I
was in high school like I was kind of
the goth person that was all into like
Bauhaus and Aliens X-Wing and everything
but then like I had friends who were
like into indie rock
um and then I had friends that were into
like old school punk rock like stiff
little fingers and stuff like that and
it's like then I had you know people
that were into like industrial stuff
like [__] uh you know throbbing
gristle and everything like that so you
all just kind of like hung out and you
liked some of the same music and you
exchanged it now Larry's in there
talking about nobody could really match
Elvis's magnetism during Peak Elvis what
he's talking about
Peak Elvis I would say it be early 70s
that was within a time when Elvis was no
longer really a rock star he was just a
star
over in Vegas he had gained some weight
but he still looked pretty good
vocally he was better than he ever was
he actually before he died he sounds
[__] great man he sounded like
[__] Luciano Pavarotti
and he was up in Vegas
and in those days a nightclub was a
stage with a bunch of booths in front of
it and people lounging around with
hookers and [__] and [__] eating and
[__] listening to music and then
they'd have I have an area up in front
where you could stand there and listen
and Elvis would do things it was almost
like a religious experience for that
generation
I saw a film in him live during one of
his Vegas performances where he was
still went before [__]
whatever drug he was on and problems he
was having before but it took over
there'd be a crowd of [__] adulating
fans in front of him and he could step
off stage down in front of a neighbor
part and he could walk through him like
he was partying the [__] Red Sea and
he could reach over and kiss some dude's
wife
and the dude wouldn't [__] do [__]
about it she's like thank you the king
you know the king you've been anointed
yeah he he was respectful about it he
wasn't all lecture and [__] but then
yeah because that would be weird but he
would just walk through it it was almost
like they were seeing Jesus
and when I was a little kid
it was kind of hard to tell the
difference between Jesus and Elvis
they'd be side by side on the [__]
mantle places above well Mississippi
that's Mississippi there's uh this is
from Mississippi and you got a picture
of Jesus on the Black Velvet and then
you got to build it
in my face just one's got a beard and
the other one's got a very much yeah
Mississippi yeah yeah Mississippi didn't
play
they thought Elvis could stop it from
raining by saying they thought that all
kinds of [__] about Elvis all right
Elvis was kind of like he's a Mythic he
was a Mythic kid yeah and they thought
he came back to life there was a dude
that made whole albums his name was
Orion oh my God if you guys haven't seen
that documentary please watch it it's so
good and Southerners Mississippi Alabama
they wanted to believe so badly that
Elvis had risen from the grave and come
back
but this dude is full grown you know
what I mean he hadn't been Devils hadn't
been dead long yeah but he sounds exact
Orion sounds exactly like Elvis he'd
wear a mask he does a lot yeah it sounds
exactly like and they're both from
Mississippi they kind of have the same
didn't he get shot in the hold up you
guys yeah you know he got shot he ended
up being owning a pawn shop and got
killed in a robbery all right I gotta
pee your top but he could sound just
like Elvis he did yeah they're just like
a documentary about it what was it
called
[__] what's that documentary called I
don't know won't you probably if you
call like Orion documentary yeah you'll
probably find it but it's really good go
ahead and play the commercials we got to
play some commercials are you sure yeah
which one just go ahead and hit
commercial one oh what'd you do I don't
know what happened oh my God okay we'll
talk about Orion when we come back all
right hold on just a second I gotta go
to the bathroom
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yeah Orion it was it was marketing
Genius of the South
you had a dude that basically looked
like Elvis like a young younger I mean
kind of like they put a mask on him and
he sounded just like [__] Elvis and
he's singing original songs
and The Motif on the [__]
album covers and on the back and on the
front is funerary kind of [__] like like
they know stuff overtly came out and
said hey I'm The Reincarnation of Elvis
but everything like kind of hinted yeah
crosses and Graves so pretty Spirit
coming out of the grave and [__] [__]
and and people in the South the fans
really wanted to believe that that was
Elvis and they were touring
and uh he was drawing huge crowds
and selling albums but they were all
local I don't think he ever went
National
not that I know of because I kind of
feel like he's mostly forgotten nowadays
even though it's a fascinating story
great story there's a whole documentary
about him yeah we saw it a while back
it's really good and uh he had the same
voice and he was from the same area
because he so he had that accent
my family's from Heidelberg and Laurel
Mississippi which is you know a couple
hours from Tupelo even though most of
most of the time Elvis was growing up in
in Nashville I believe does it Nashville
or
it was I think he was well I know he was
born in Tupelo but I don't remember like
I think he left there when he was a kid
when he was like a teenager I think he
ended up being in Nashville most
but he had uh he had a
Mississippi
dialect that he picked up from his
from his mom his dad you know his family
so uh and it's it's a retro dialect but
you know I hear it and it sounds all my
dad's friends talk like my dad kind of
talks like that
they did a DNA test he's not related to
Elvis in any way because sometimes like
they they thought they thought that but
he's not it's like oh maybe Elvis like
hum some chick that had a baby that
didn't tell him no it's just kind of the
same ethnic group
because he does sound a lot like him
yeah he really does and um
a lot of Elvis fans will also listen to
[__] Orion kind of like extended
Universe it's like Elvis it is yes it is
like fanfic like Elvis fanfic yeah
that's exactly what it is yeah which
like I said that's a pretty Earl I mean
as early as that happened that's like a
pretty Genius Like marketing that's what
they're doing right they're extending
the universe right they're they're doing
fanfic it's like we're not saying
outright that I'm Elvis reincarnated but
you want to believe that don't you but
if you want to believe that we're gonna
give you like a few little kind of vades
yeah imagery and stuff like that and it
was gospel in any singing gospel yeah
yeah which like I said I don't have I
mean I was um
in high school I sang in a choir yeah
and we did some gospel kind of stuff and
yeah I I kind of liked that actually and
the albums never say his name
they just call him Orion yeah yeah I
don't even remember what his real name
is maybe we should do a show about that
we gotta do a whole [__] show on that
dude yeah because like I said that that
documentary was that was that was like
fascinating it was fascinating like that
whole kind of because I kind of feel
like it's largely forgotten nowadays but
it was kind of like a big deal at the
time and it's just kind of like
and it's kind of sad what happened to
him too but I mean the way that he died
was you know what happened was he was
wearing a mask yeah
and people were suspending their
disbelief and his his career was going
well
he started to get big-headed he was like
look I'm gonna take this mask off and
tell everybody who I really am and Susan
took that mask off they were like no no
take the mask off don't do it don't do
it see I took the mask off they go ah
they him you're not elevator that was
the end of his career yeah should have
never taken that [__] mask off
that was the gimmick I get it that was
the gimmick like he was just kind of
like sick of being like oh maybe I'm
Elvis reincarnated like I can see how if
you're a creative person you're like
look I want to be appreciated for me
like I want to do my own [__] like I get
that but it's just kind of like your
whole bread and butter yeah is people
disbelief
is like schroding yourself I mean it's
just kind of like that was the whole
appeal they knew he wasn't Elvis I know
they wanted to [__] believe that he
was Elvis all right and as long as you
had that ambiguity yeah you could still
maintain that illusion yeah you knew it
wasn't true you knew that wasn't Elvis
he was selling that illusion with sure
very high quality [__] singing and
music is very high quality it was as
good as Elvis stuff
Dave says I listened to a podcast where
somebody was very dismissive about Ska
music accusing it of cultural
appropriation but it was such a positive
thing and a massive up yours to the
National front yeah I do kind of feel
like that was
that's the thing like I said a lot of
people that were into marginalized or
alternative what they would call
alternative music like back in the 80s
um you know they were kind of like doing
their own thing and a lot of that was
like a lot of punks listen to reggae
particularly in the UK like back at that
time period And so Scott emerged out of
that so I don't think I mean they
weren't appropriating anything that's
[__] a lot of those band members
were Jamaica yeah they were immigrants
yeah it was not appropriation it was a
joint venture right between British guys
and Jamaican guys they were in the
[__] band and honestly like a lot of
white dude like [__] Bauhaus one of my
favorite bands they were like a couple
of people listen to reggae and like um
some of their if you listen to like
their uh album mask which I think is
their favorite was their best one like
from 82. there's some stuff that's very
reggae infused on there because Daniel
Ash was like really into reggae and so
it has like a lot of Reggae influence
like especially in like the rhythms and
stuff like the original sky had a lot of
black members in the band it was a joint
venture but it was so good
British white bands had to have a
response they had to have [__] scar
music in it or they had to have some
kind of you know some kind of a ska song
so they would just do it as a response
it wouldn't have anything to
appropriation that's a modern [__]
concept back in those days ago it was
just called adaptation and [__]
seeing something that was good and using
it and going yeah inspiration you know
yeah like that's cool that's all it was
you know what I mean and they were kind
of honoring all that [__] so no that's
[__] I mean I don't I don't know
like yeah I can see how it's kind of
shitty in some situ situations but I'm
thinking of you know since we're talking
about Post Punk and stuff like that look
at somebody like the birthday party you
know Nick Cave's old band who were
Australian and they were really into
American delta blues music yeah so they
fake southern music they got really into
that but they cross-pollinated it yeah
with Punk Post Punk like noise and it
was like it was kind of a genius
combination but it's like you know Nick
Cave is like super super you know he's
in a whole like [__] blues album yeah
and you don't hear the firstborn is dead
you know in 80s
Mississippi [__] like me most
of the Mississippi [__] don't
know who [__] Nick Cave is okay but
you don't hear us complaining hey that's
a fake Southern song man that's been
going on forever he didn't whole song
about about the myth about Elvis's birth
and his twin and everything and it's
called Tupelo yeah it's a great song by
the way but and it's a whole story about
like Elvis and his twin being born dead
and all this other kind of stuff the
thing is like a messiah thing the thing
is though is the [__] you know um
he's not the first one to do that no of
course not I mean [__] the Rolling
Stones made an entire career out of
Faking southern music sure wild horses
and all that [__] and [__] and then
uh what was it bad girls what was that
one was this some girls I think it was
called some girls I think it's the name
of the song they're all singing with
Southern
Mississippi accents and [__]
people from Mississippi didn't get mad
what they're talking about you know I
mean they're
I mean like I said a Mississippi hockey
talk and then [__] would play
wild horses not knowing that that was a
British band they didn't you know yeah
yeah yeah put it on Southern music they
because it was southern music we
listened to it which is funny to me
though yeah you wouldn't realize that
but yeah I mean in the end it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
really matter it doesn't matter I kind
of feel like it was a good song
it was a little exaggerated Mick Jagger
would exaggerate the southern accent
quite sure you know the draw was too
long on a lot of that
but um it was still good
yeah as long as it's a good song I'm not
mad about it Mick Jagger was a [__]
genius like just don't be a tool about
it between beetles and the stones I'd
have to give it to the stones an overall
energy level I'd give it to the Beatles
in terms of [__] interesting
Innovation sure but in terms of Gestalt
I'm a huge beetles fan yeah so I'm kind
of biased in terms of Gestalt and the
[__] feeling behind it and the
[__] I'd give it an emotion I would
give it to Rolling Stones Rolling Stones
actually started goth music but [__]
painted black and some some of their
[__] just even satisfaction kind of had
an early goth [__] feel to it it's
like
Sisters of Mercy was actually you know
was actually kind of like a [__]
Rolling Stones rip-off
uh what was his name Andrew Eldridge
said he wanted his he wanted the
citizens of Mercy to be something kind
of like the Rolling Stones yeah well
they covered yeah they did a lot of
Rolling Stones actually sisters
well the thing about it though is that
goth music I kind of feel like it was
well you had prior to that you had
screaming Jay Hawkins
I think that was a cover though
what screaming Jay Hawkins song [__]
um I Put a Spell on You what's that no
that was the original like a lot of
people like covered it because I heard
there was an earlier one oh maybe there
was an earlier one before that that was
actually I liked it even better I don't
think it was screaming Jay Hawkins I I
Put a Spell on You I think screaming Jay
Hawkins was doing a cover
I was pretty sure that that was the
original but maybe not no it's not the
original it was the second one
Jeffy Hart says FYI I watched the eyes
of Tammy Faye great movie yeah we
watched that for them yeah it's a good
movie uh if the movie's depiction of Jim
Baker was even half accurate what a tool
yeah he's a tool yeah he was a tool they
were all still is a tool yeah I mean
Tammy was the best one that [__] is
still alive yeah yeah Tammy's the only
one that's dead yeah that really made me
upset yeah because I was like well that
proves there's no God right there yeah
Tammy was that Tammy was that of the
televangelist Tammy I think was kind of
the most innocent of them she was the
only one that actually seemed to be like
an okay person yeah like I'm not saying
she was a great person I'm just saying
out of all of them I mean it's a low bar
I get that but it's like she didn't mean
any harm she didn't really seem to be
mean anymore no the other ones were
actively evil I kind of feel like
so you know but yeah it I really did
like that movie I didn't realize it was
that new because I was thinking of there
was a documentary called The Eyes of
Tammy Faye it had like the same title
and that came out in the early 2000s I
think and I think that's what I was
thinking of and I was like oh they made
a fictional movie about it and it's like
that's what we watched and I was like
holy [__] that was only like a couple of
years ago that was like 2021 I didn't
realize it was that new
uh let's see uh Larry says hell yeah the
British Invasion was just that's where
it's selling you Yanks the blues back
with more Distortion and a quicker beat
yeah
I mean how long we've been playing uh
two hours and 51 minutes this has been a
three hour stream well like I said we're
having a good time okay it's Saturday
night we're not going anywhere yeah it's
that kind of thing
it's only quarter to nine but yeah um I
wanted you to comment on this because
Larry said the British Invasion was just
us Brits selling kids Larry's British
selling you Yanks the blues back with
more Distortion yeah somebody else did I
mean essentially yeah
everybody says Dave says I'm with Tom if
we hadn't adapted we'd have nothing but
classical and full music you'd have
white dudes still wearing funny ass
[__] socks with [__] stripes on
them and [__] [__] at the top yeah
you have to have outside influences
yeah I mean you hear something good if
you hear something good it doesn't
matter you know it doesn't matter where
it comes from you go oh that's a good
idea
Japan is built on that there's nothing
original in Japan in Japan everything
Japan has made out of is borrowed from
overseas pretty much except they're
traditional [__] but all their modern
stuff is all a mishmash of [__]
what's happening in the outside world
everybody's like that now hi pookie we
have tele we have tele we have
telecommunications all right that
changes the game
everyone can see what everybody else is
doing so that means everyone influences
everybody now
yeah Larry said music doesn't belong to
any particular type of color or Creed
it's not human and yeah I kind of do
feel like like I said I get it I get the
arguments but everybody takes
inspiration from what they hear and what
they like and
I kind of that's a good thing I kind of
feel like you should incorporate
look at it this way sand of saying white
guys can't do blues music is like saying
black people can't do classical like oh
you can't do classical that's white
music you can't you can't do that
no it's just people are just people you
hear some [__] you see some [__] go yeah
I'm a I like that I'm gonna [__] do
my own version I'm gonna do my own
version yeah yeah well I kind of feel
like artists is all doing that like
forever they've been doing it forever
yeah you just get
yeah I mean it's even the Vikings were
borrowing from the Romans
okay they would just say look that's
that that's called an alphabet we need
one of those that's a good idea yeah
that's a good idea Viking runes Viking
runes were built on the [__] Roman
alphabet you know so it's just it's just
it is what it is everybody is is
influenced by other people
nothing's really well that's really kind
of the way everything is yeah and like I
said if you see something and like you
like that [__] it's just kind of like
and you want to make your own version of
that I think that's like kind of flat
yeah uh Larry said also Tom what's your
favorite classic Star Trek episode I
know you're oh the favorite classic Star
Trek original series episode would be
um Mirror Mirror
the [__]
the mirror the first mirror episode with
fast fock
yeah I got it and then I got my Mary and
then the second version
yeah and then and then the sequel to it
in Star Trek Continues called fairest of
them all which says which which tells
you what that Spock did played by Kirk
habricorn [__] uh Todd Capricorn yeah
if you liked if you liked Mirror Mirror
see fairest of them all on YouTube for
free
on Star Trek Continues it's [__]
great episode what was the one where
Scotty got accused of like murder
because of like the whole chapter yeah
that was wolf in the fold wolf in the
wolf and the fold yeah I think that's I
liked the I love original Star Trek I'm
not like super into like the other ones
but I love original Star Trek because I
love Spock I love that whole like
Trifecta yeah of you know bones and Kirk
and Spock I love that [__] like another
good one was one with a hoarder
but I think like I like the horror
themed ones I like the scary ones so I
liked wolf in the fold because it was
like Jack the Ripper themed and like
Scotty got like accused of murder
because of like the they went back to
like some other I can't remember exactly
what happened it's been like a couple
years since we watched them we actually
watch the original Star Trek series
every two or three years yeah like we
watch all another good one was I think
was called balance of Terror where oh
yeah yeah that was where there was a
secret mission to steal the rhyme and
then cloaking device and [__] what
was it [__] spark had to seduce the
Robin and female Captain remember that's
right she's trying to get him to come
back to Romulus with him okay yeah that
was good that was good that was a good
one yeah and you don't know what the
[__] is going on and then you find it oh
it's a secret mission this is all
[__] he's not defecting he's trying
to steal the [__] cloaking device
that was a great one oh [__] what was
the one where they went where they went
to that planet and then like they went
into the place it was like a haunted
house oh yeah yeah yeah you remember
that one what was that one oh [__] what
was the name of that somebody knows it
turns out they were little aliens right
right they were just oh I like that one
too like I said yeah it was like an old
like Gothic Castle or whatever yeah like
I really like it was similar to the
other episode where you had
uh the the alien child that thought he
was Napoleon cat's paw that's it the
other one where it turns out there's a
super human alien child that's toying
with the Enterprise and the crew and it
turns out did the parents show up going
oh this is our child he's just playing
and you go like oh you're they're
talking about the Q that this is a child
cue from the Q Continuum which were
god-like beings which is funny because
they parodied that later on History
Science Theater yeah where they had like
space children that came in and like
then their parents came and got them and
like they had omniscient Powers another
good one was the one where Kirk where
the defiant gets pulled into a parallel
universe it goes with it he's like a
ghost yeah and there's in the second
part of that ends up in the Mirror
Universe
the last step two mirror universes is an
inner in the series Enterprise where the
it turns out that it was the [__]
thalians that stole the [__]
Enterprise they stole the defiant in the
future and took it back to the past and
[__] Captain Archer and the mirror
Captain archers bought the information
to found out that to find out that the
[__]
dollyans had a [__]
Earth ship from the future from 200
years in the future and he was trying to
[__] steal it
to [__] and sell it back to the
Empire he says I'll [__] it then he
because the empire was like oh it's okay
we're they were just gonna take it from
him so that he mutinies and uses the
tries to use the Enterprise to take over
the [__] Terran Empire that was a
[__] good I'm speaking of me want to
watch the OG like The Originals yeah we
will watch it again the Garn episode was
[__] good I mean that's always fun
yeah
I believe he's making gunpowder [__]
Spock and [__] spot's my favorite yeah I
was like you guys don't know like our
friend our friend [__] Laura Ross no
relation to me
we got the same last name
Laura's and we almost look related
actually you do kind of yeah we don't
sleep really but uh she [__] she sent
Jen and Laura have a crush on Leonard
the boy as [__] okay
we're trading pictures Florida just
recently discovered yeah the OG yeah uh
Leonard demoy like from the back in the
day because she's significantly younger
than we are yeah so it's like I was
talking to her about it like a few
months ago we were at mannequins and she
just got on the Leonard Nimoy train yeah
and like especially like the Spock thing
so she's been like sending me like
pictures but it's like look at this one
like that I found and it's like you know
what I mean and it's like oh my God it's
like a girl's lasting over [__]
Leonard or more we love Millennium yeah
I mean I I was a big fan of uh the
original Star Trek and I also love uh uh
in search of yeah that's a good series
yeah uh Larry says I love the OG
Twilight Zone and outer limits too yeah
I do too I we also rewatched the
Twilight Zone like every piece well they
had a lot and if what I'm just gonna say
I'm gonna plug my other Channel all
right if you don't know I have another
Channel called the scare salon and I
have been working through the Boris
Karloff Thriller series from the 1960s
like it's slow going because it was a
lot of episodes you mentioned Laura
that's Laura
right there the one on the that one
which one is left and which one is right
well that's Jen and that's Laura okay
yeah yes that's that's who we're talking
about Laura let's recommend yeah it's
like I just I think that's hilarious
that she got like super new well like
she told me one night I think we were
mannequins and we were like out of the
patio and she was like oh my God I just
like [__] discovered this whole
Leonard Nimoy thing like the whole spot
thing and I was just kind of like
[__] we get we got to sit down and
discuss this
wasn't just you though I was talking to
her too she's like and she's like now
she's like sending me pictures like look
at this [__] that I found like some like
obscure thing that he was in and I'm
just like oh man she's like look how
[__] hot I didn't realize the
original series was that good like they
had good stuff oh my God yeah and it's
just and she's and she's like why is why
is Spock so hot
and I said yes I said like well you
gotta understand don't think about it
too much yeah he just is I said I said
you gotta understand when they first
wrote that they thought that that the
Kirk character would be kind of like the
sex symbol of the [__]
series but it turned out that
Kirk ended up being the most popular
with the males all right the guys liked
Kirk
because he was kind of an alpha type all
right but the women like Spock because
he was the unattainable dude
he was unattainable we liked him you
couldn't get him he didn't have emotion
you know what I mean but they constantly
were writing these [__] kind of
romantic well he didn't play with that
character he was controlling him yeah
he's controlling his emotions and then
they they could write
romantic episodes about him being
tempted right there's always this female
fantasy of tempting a dude that's like
doesn't he's resisting you right it's
hard to get and you could tempt him into
well because you want to be the special
[__] yeah to get him that like
gets him away from so that's what the
right right like I get that that that's
what the appeal of the spot character so
I think that's what what was the one
where they went to the planet where
everything was like super awesome and
like [__] hippie dippy and everything
and like and Spock even like fell in
love with a woman he's like I'm not
going back to him what was that what was
that oh that was the one where they had
the plants yeah yeah yeah it was an ant
where it like spot it shot like sports
star spores and it made you real passive
and loving and [__] and what that what's
like the hippie plan what they were
talking about is LSD well yeah yeah
they're talking about LSD and they were
talking about the hip the hippie
generation if yeah you could sit around
be high and love each other but you
can't get any work done that was the the
that was the
yeah you can't get any work done and
that that's you know and then and [__]
will fall apart there won't be a [__]
there won't be a civilization no one
will be around to like run [__] yeah you
can't run anything so that's what it was
about sadly yeah uh Larry says I'd love
to hang out with you guys one time I
love all this [__]
I know I do too but yeah I'm
I really need to get back into it I've
been covering I'm gonna start doing
Night Gallery too but it's like I've
only done the pilot so far because I
love Night Gallery but I've been doing
the the Boris Karloff Thriller series
from 1960 1961 I think it ran two
seasons or three seasons and I um there
were like 67 episodes I want to say
there were a lot so I've been like kind
of
doing videos where I'm kind of doing
like six episode chunks and I haven't
really been able to like watch a lot of
them but I really do like now I will say
that a lot of them aren't horror because
I'm more like a horror girl and they're
more like suspense so they're more like
Alfred Hitchcock Presents type stuff but
maybe not even but you know
a lot of them are really good and like a
lot of the uh writing is really good as
well but yeah I have like a couple other
channels
scare salon and I have a channel called
crime and Memorial but I haven't posted
anything on there for a while because I
haven't had a time but you know I I've
been trying to like kind of work through
that I'm trying I was gonna do call
check as well I was gonna do like the
cold tracks here I did the movies
um I did a video about the two pilot
movies like colchuck The Night Stalker
and colchuck tonight Strangler I think
they were called and I did those and I
said well I need to get into doing the
series too but I'm gonna wait till I'm
done with Thriller and then I was up I'm
gonna do Night Gallery to you so that's
gonna take forever
uh Linwood says I had a crush on Seven
of Nine so uh
uh Pearl Jam I'm assuming you mean Pearl
Jam perform in Hershey Pennsylvania in
the 2000s
um Black Sabbath it's a great Karloff
movie I agree I love Boris Karloff Boris
Karloff is [__] amazing I will watch
anything that Boris Karloff is in he's
another one of those dudes that I'm in
I'm kind of into Boris Karloff gonna say
I think my favorite role as much as I
live Frankenstein now Bride of
Frankenstein is kind of like the the oh
the the the kind of peak of that but I'm
gonna say
Boris Karloff
um I really liked him in the mummy
he ever see he was great in the moment
but I have to say my favorite movie or
his my favorite role of his would have
been the black cat yeah
uh that was him and Bella yeah yeah
that's a great [__] movie
Herald Zig I think is what his name was
a Sharma right yeah or something like
that it was a satanic ex-military
officer that has was this pre-code
pre-code I think this was a pre-code
sacrificed his military unit on a
[__] Battleground to [__]
consecrate the ground that he wanted to
build this high-tech satanic
Castle on
where he
stole the wife and daughter of one of
his [__] men it's kind of [__] up
right and he had him one he had he did
embalmed down in the [__] glass yeah
he's got them all in kind of stuffed he
had a bunch of women down there stuffed
and they kind of implied that he's still
having sex with him and then he had
[__] vitus's [__]
daughter he still had her and she was
[__] hot and young and [__] [__]
these [__] gowns he's sheer [__]
satanic gowns and he's got a satanic
[__] people coming and he's [__]
Holden church services and [__]
and Vitus [__] who's played by uh
Bella Legos he's just released from the
cool Gall which is like this military
prison you know he and he's going back
he realized what what his his unit
Commander had done sacrificed the unit
and stole his wife and [__]
the weird thing about that movie we did
a review of IT a while back it's called
the black cat but it doesn't have
nothing to do with it it's nothing to do
with the Edgar Allan poster shoehorned
that in there yeah well it's
recognizable it's a [__] story of
Satanism Human Sacrifice necrophilia
torture peeling off people's skin yeah
uh [__]
high-tech [__] for the time [__] like
in this little castle that had sliding
doors like and intercoms like some [__]
out of the [__]
Star Trek Enterprise
it's a good movie all black and white
and what was it 1930 when did that come
out five maybe something like that I
can't remember we like we had a review
of it but yeah it's 30s yeah but it was
pre-code though I thought yeah they got
away with yeah I mean it's tame by
today's standards obviously but they got
away with a lot it's not tame when you
think about what they're talking about
yeah the implication of it you're right
he's got Venus with him and he he goes
where's Karen and he goes I have her
I'll show you you know what I mean she's
in this glad he takes her down to the
bottom and she's in this glass casket
standing up like that she looked at the
brighter Frankenstein kind of all
beautiful in this glass casket and he
goes what happened to her because she
died you know soon after giving birth I
think that's what she said did he said
he goes why is she in here and she goes
so I could always have her beauty
it's just going on and you're like and
it's kind of implied it's kind of
implied that he's having sex with that
yeah like baby popping it out yeah and
then there's like some other ones
weren't there some other women
in there I think he had a bunch he had a
bunch of them I mean it's been a while
since yeah and [__] vedus who's
played by Bella goes he's high on now I
can't take this [__] and it turns out
that [__] the daughter his daughter
Venus's daughter
that came out of Karen they're still
running around and he's using her as the
substitute wife
so you know yeah there's all kind of
just kind of holding there is a sex
slave but just uh she doesn't know any
better like I said they couldn't really
come out and say stuff like that but
like if you thought about it yeah you're
like wait like man this is [__] up
yeah this whole the whole application of
it is very [__] up
Larry says oh yeah [__] colchack Night
Stalker is such a good movie see he's 28
and he knows like Kolchak yeah that's
awesome that's awesome
um and Larry said I love reading
pre-code e horror comics too got loads
of repents of the EC stuff yeah all the
[__] was good and like I said we're
talking about pre-code like pre-haze
code which is
um Hollywood and that was when did the
haze code come in 1930
2 35 I can't remember but we did a whole
show about it but um you wanna drink I
got Sly over there what's up Sly I
haven't heard you in a while yeah man we
gotta end this show eventually I'm just
gonna give you some of this
oh don't be that way well Saturday
it's only nine yeah but I got I gotta
get something to eat man okay you're not
gonna die
Dave says for three hours I know Dave
says I grew up watching and loving
colchach he was born a Colombo style
cool character and a precursor to the
likes of agent Mulder yeah that's what I
said on my show it's that um you know
Chris Carter the guy that created
X-Files was a big fan of colchack and
wanted so Kolchak is like the pre if you
like X-Files you should probably go back
and watch the cold check series because
that's what he based it on essentially
uh Linwood says Tom get you any other
drink
women problems
it's not really a problem he's just like
getting me another drink
uh yeah Larry said for sure Dave totally
an inspiration for X-Files yeah and I
think I mentioned that on my review and
so if you like the X-Files please go
back and watch cold Jack I haven't done
the series yet but I did do the two like
pilot movies and I'm eventually gonna
get around to doing the series but
I don't know how long it's gonna take
because I'm still doing Thriller and I'm
still doing Night Gallery and I'm still
doing all these other kind of things
uh let's see
I I don't know what that means but okay
so you're not gonna give me another
drink just you gotta drink right there
you just gave me like a legend right
there yep okay you gotta keep that [__]
out of control I gotta make us something
to eat here in a bit what you can make
well I got I got Carnitas already made
up so I can make oh that's right or I
can do it with burritos or I haven't I
can make um I got you some uh soy sauce
flavored Ramen
from the from the uh
from from the Latino store
went to Latina grocery store when did
you do that yesterday oh okay and then
um
or day before yesterday and then um see
what else I can do
I had to thaw out crab if you want crab
salad
well it takes a while yeah I don't thaw
anything I'll thaw the crab out for
later
I also have I also have
um pork tenderloin thought
but that'll take a while to cook
nine something about just Carnitas yeah
okay I mean I agreements with it
yesterday and that was really good tacos
are burritos pretty much
um let's do a burrito okay because we
had time I got flour tortillas yeah it's
like oh [__] I have a bunch of stuff in
the dryer too I'll get that out yeah we
gotta we gotta [__] do life stuff
I've been here for three hours man I
know well like I said we're having a
good time and it's like we weren't going
anywhere so we were just kind of like
relaxing and drinking and talking to you
guys I enjoy it
uh yeah because Larry was asking what
you guys gonna have to eat tonight yeah
so I guess we're gonna have burritos
with carnitas well like I said he made
Carnitas like the other day and then we
had tacos with it yesterday and those
were delicious I made burritos yeah
burrito would be good all right so
hopefully you guys have had a good time
hanging out with us on this Saturday
evening
um tomorrow is Sunday so we might do a
movie do you do you want to talk about
nope
let me talk about no because we watched
nope yeah the Jordan peel movie yeah you
can see it free on what it's all well
it's on Amazon like if you have an
Amazon Prime subscription you can watch
that well that's why I watched it
because I was like oh they added that
okay do I peel sci-fi horror Kinda Yeah
Yeah it was interesting it was
interesting I'm gonna say like I didn't
like it as much as get out or us no but
it's still pretty interesting though
it's still like I liked the I liked the
vibe of it I like the direction my only
complaint is a little bit slow in the in
the first time in the first half yeah
but yeah we'll talk about that
um but yeah we did watch nope so we're
gonna talk about that tomorrow probably
so tune in for that probably do it at 6
p.m Eastern Standard Time so uh yeah
Larry says Uh there's always next time
have a good one uh all right so
Jeffy Hart said I love nope yeah okay so
we're gonna I thought it was okay yeah
it was pretty good so we're gonna talk
about that tomorrow so thank you
everybody for hanging out with us this
evening we're gonna go eat and uh we'll
see you guys again tomorrow
good night